The Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Right?
We're live.
We can't hear ourselves because Brian
Cox,
even though he's a musician,
he goes,
no headphone where we can still hear us.
I can hear you.
You're right.
I just can't hear whether or not,
but we wouldn't know.
Anyway.
What would we do?
He knows he's got headphones on.
You're right.
This is revolutionary from now on.
No more headphones.
It's ridiculous.
What would you use them for?
Well,
it's like watching television while
you're on television.
It's like if you were on TV and you were
watching a video monitor,
it seems weird.
Yeah,
it's a little redundant.
I think we should leave.
Cast them aside.
Yeah,
let's just a revolutionary act.
Push them.
Push them away.
Like not just put them down.
We reject you.
Oh,
headphones.
We reject you.
Amazing technology.
Infinite monkey cage.
Yeah.
What's going on,
man?
What is this?
First of all,
I'm a huge fan of your work.
I said that when he came in,
but I have to tell people online.
This is a huge treat for me.
I'm very excited.
Space has been my all time adult freak
out.
Pleasure.
I love watching space documentaries.
I love watching television shows on
space.
So having you in here is a huge treat.
Thank you.
What's infinite monkey cage?
It's a long running now,
a BBC radio show.
So the idea initially was to get
scientists to talk about their science,
whatever it may be.
You said cosmology or archeology?
Human origins,
mathematics,
everything.
And then I do it with a standup comedian
called Robin Inns.
It's very good friend of mine and we
always also invite another guest who
will be a comedian sometimes or an actor
or someone who will kind of ask those
questions that come in from left field
and.
But it always goes off into some as as
your podcast do it just,
you never know where it's going to go.
So we're gonna call it a front of a live
audience,
usually London and we record for about
two hours,
usually in broadcast every about 30
minutes and as a podcast as well,
which is a bit longer,
but we decided to bring it to the states
because there are lots of scientists in
the states,
lots of comedians and people like
yourself that you're going to do it with
us in three weeks in their wealth of
Thursday,
the twelfth in La and so we just want
it.
So we're going to record them for the
BBC and they're going to be on the
podcast and broadcast in the UK but also
in front of a live audience.
So it's a.
someone asked me this morning actually,
and I said,
it's kind of like a variety show that
you had an accent.
Do you have those in the states?
They said yeah,
we used to have them.
We used to happen the and used to do
one.
So I said,
well it's kind of like Dave Dimartino
had a phd and he would have.
It would have been that black and white,
a bit of singing and dancing,
bit of quantum mechanics basically.
That's one of the things that's so
important about what you do,
what Neil degrasse Tyson does is that
you guys,
you,
you were entertaining as well as having
a genuine passion and a deep knowledge
of science.
So it's not just like here's the cold
hard facts,
which are amazing and fascinating on
their own,
but you guys both have this way of sort
of germinating these ideas into people's
minds that might not ordinarily accept
them because,
uh,
there's a lot of people in America
especially that associate learning with
boring.
Well,
I think the,
the important point series point science
is too important not to be part of
popular culture.
So if we.
Popular Culture is the thing that people
discuss.
So if we seed that to talent shows or
sports or whatever it is,
then we're removing the most important
area of human endeavor out of general
conversation.
So I think there's a very,
there's a responsibility on scientists
to say,
well,
I accept that.
Of course,
I can't talk at the level that I let you
out at a as an undergraduate lecture
course at university or even a Postgrad,
electrical,
so the level of my thesis and my
research,
I can't do that,
but it's extremely important that we
don't just see all the ground.
We don't want people in in bars tonight
or wherever in restaurants to only talk
to be talking about the grammys last
night.
We like them to be talking about the
fact that the universe may be infinite
in extent that asking questions such as
how many civilizations other in the
Milky Way Galaxy,
the question,
the answer might be not very many.
If that's true,
then what does that mean for the way
that we behave?
These are important questions,
but they will never be debated it unless
we take the time and and make the effort
to to,
to make the science and the ideas and
the debate around them.
Part of popular culture,
the Internet has also opened up a lot of
people's ideas about what science can be
and also it opened up a lot of people's
ideas about the actual popularity of
science because there's,
until,
you know,
maybe 10,
20 years ago with the notable exception
of like maybe Carl Sagan and a few other
famous people that became famous for,
you know,
uh,
either cosmologists are mathematicians.
It's very,
very rare.
But now you're seeing guys like
yourself,
guys like Neil degrasse Tyson.
It's like more and more Richard Dawkins,
Christopher Hitchens,
while he's alive,
these interesting intellectuals become
much more mainstream.
They become a.
because people realized it wasn't that
folks weren't interested in these
subjects before it was this.
They really weren't being presented
them.
If you don't get enough ratings,
if you put your show on Thursday night
at 8:00
PM and you don't get x amount of number
of people watching,
the studio loses interest.
The people that produce it start looking
at other jobs.
I,
well,
this one wasn't going to work and they
start moving on.
And that's just the reality of
television.
And I think that with the Internet,
people are able to look at some of these
subjects and,
and you know,
someone will send out a tweet or a
facebook link or something like that,
and then you'll say,
well,
this got a million people to look at it
over the last 12 weeks.
And the,
this has
sort of,
instead of having this immediate
timeframe where everybody has to pay
attention or the show dies,
now ideas are allowed to sort of grow.
Yeah,
I think you're absolutely right about
that.
I think we as a culture underestimate
people.
I think this is what you found with your
podcast.
I think that there are millions of
people out there who are interested in
ideas interested in the latest things we
found out about the universe and nature
and the way that it works.
Um,
and they'll,
they'll come to it.
You can,
you build an audience,
I suppose,
and it's very important for the reasons
that I outlined our civilization,
Carl Sagan,
I always used to say that our
civilization is based on science and
technology.
And so in democracies,
if your democracy is going to function
properly,
then people need to know about the
cutting edge discoveries and the things
that we found out which form the basis
of our civilization.
Otherwise,
how can your democracy function
properly.
So that's partly the responsibility of
the education system of course,
but I see actually the media on the
Internet and actually on television and
radio as part of the education system
now I know that the media doesn't see
itself as that often exceeds itself as a
a corporate effort to generate money for
shareholders that I.
I'd criticize that quite strongly
actually,
and we were fortunate in Britain that
we've got the BBC whose job it is to be
part of the education system.
In part it's,
it's.
It is a national institution.
So having a strong public service
broadcaster I think is is one of the
best things you can do as a country.
I mean,
imagine a American.
I know it will be an anathema to the big
corporations who run the TV channels,
but imagine you had a channel which
which really had a lot of money to BBC
is well funded that everybody
contributed to in the states whose job
was to act in the interests of the
nation,
whose job it was to say,
well,
we're going to put these.
We're going to make these big signs
documentaries and put them on,
and yet we'll make entertainment shows
and drama shows as well.
We're going to make them because we
think people need to know this stuff.
We want to infuse the next generation of
scientists and engineers.
That's.
That's important actually.
It's important not to expose people
continually to,
to,
you know,
drivel basically populists driven
because people.
I think you're right.
People want to think,
I really believed that people are
interested.
I rarely go into a bar or a restaurant
or a party and people say,
what do you do?
And anybody say,
well,
I work at the large Hadron collider at
cern in Geneva.
We recreate the conditions that were
present less than a billion two the
second after the big bang.
It's very rare that someone just says
whatever and it goes until somebody else
they're interested.
Sure.
So I,
uh,
yeah,
I think the,
and maybe you're right,
the optimistic view as you say,
is that the,
the,
the Internet,
we'll remove this culprit layer of
middle management in a way this kind of
the television executive,
but maybe if you can remove that filter.
She's like,
I thought
the malfunctioning kidney in the flow of
information,
maybe it,
it,
it's a,
it's a good thing in a way it is,
uh,
it's,
it's really kind of an archaic idea.
The idea that you know,
at,
you know,
Thursday night at 8:00,
that's when the show airs,
airs for an hour.
Well now you could of course dvr things
and you can,
of course there's a lot of television
shows up,
things on demand,
so you can download them later.
But I think that that's the model,
the model is the distribution through
the internet and this idea of sending
things through the satellites and all
the way they're doing it now with
television networks,
it's like it's.
It's not gonna work,
it's not gonna last,
as soon as companies like Netflix and
now Amazon is creating their own
television shows as well.
There are Internet based companies and
they truly understand what the Internet
is all about and when Amazon or rather
when Netflix releases a series,
they released the entire series who can
download like all 10 episodes,
you can binge watch them,
which is a great way to get people
hooked on shows as well.
This idea that the only way you're going
to watch something is if it's on NBC or
CBS or ABC and then those people that
run those networks,
they're in a panic because they got to
get people to watch.
So they'll throw on some reality show.
But housewives that are fighting to the
death and people tune in.
I mean this is I hosted fear factor.
You know,
I,
I understand what they're doing.
I was a part of the problem or part of
the solution,
if that's what you wanted to watch on
television,
you know,
the,
they're just trying to get by,
like they're just trying to figure out
what's the next American idol,
what's the next,
you know,
whatever.
Show the voice,
like what do I have to do to get 18
million people who sit in front and
watch a ball being passed from one man
to the other and they try to get across
the line and everybody goes crazy.
This,
this idea that that's the only way we
can get our information.
The only way you're going to get
entertainment or any,
anything that's coming at you that's
being produced and created,
that's dead.
They.
What I find interesting about this
debate there is it,
the media is obviously tremendously
powerful.
Obviously they,
they interface between most people and
ideas.
Um,
and so I worry about,
uh,
the,
the increase of choice in a sense.
So it's a very good thing in some
respects,
but in other respects that you can get
to eyes,
audiences,
audiences will become,
get to.
Yes.
So let's say that for example,
I am interested in playing computer
games,
so,
so as a,
as a 17 year old something interview,
if that's what you're into,
you can just watch that 24 slash seven
you just so you're not exposed to new
ideas.
So I would say is that choice really the
choice is really what you mean is
enfolding choice.
So you mean well here,
here's the spread of ideas that our
culture has generated over you no more
than 3000 years of civilization and you,
you will stumble across things you
didn't know about.
Maybe you become interested in ancient
Egypt.
Maybe it could become interested in the,
the,
the evolution of Homo Sapiens,
the Rift Valley 200,000
years ago.
Maybe you find that fascinating,
but it,
if you're not exposed to those ideas,
oh,
and culture has no way of exposing you
to those ideas beyond the education
system.
Then we were in a.
We have a problem.
So I,
I don't know what the solution is to
this,
but I think that there's,
there's a,
there's something to be said.
It will never come back now.
But the old fashioned model that we had
in Britain for many years,
where the BBC was really quite dominant,
was that you could almost,
you could say,
well,
we're going to put x factor on,
let's say,
or dancing with the stars or whatever
that thing is.
And then after we're going to put a
documentary on about astronomy and the
idea is that some of that,
the people who were watching the talent
show it will drift into the documentary
guy I didn't know I was interested in
the moon of Jupiter called Europa as an
ocean surrounding it.
They may have life on it.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know I was interested and that
that model works.
So you're right though,
it's gone.
Probably.
So I think the great challenge is how do
you,
how do you expose people to new ideas in
our culture?
How do you get debates going?
How do you stimulate that kind of
excitement about knowledge in this new
media world?
Maybe you know,
but you're sort of an evangelist in that
sense.
Then you're.
I don't mean it in in a religious way.
I mean,
you're,
you're someone who evangelizes about the
ideas of science and of space like you
think it's very important to spread
these ideas and that 17 year old kid who
watched his video games all day,
which easily could've been me,
that that kid will never break out of
that mold.
I think that the.
I think the 17 year old kid,
if he wants to,
if he really is completely obsessed and
he wants to watch video games all day,
the only thing that's going to fix that
is just going to eventually get bored
and he's going to want to try something
new and having the infinite options that
are available today.
Someone could send him a text.
Dude,
three words.
Infinite monkey cage.
Yeah,
Google it and the guy,
he'll be right.
Shit,
I'm bored with video games and then
he'll have access to all kinds of shit
that like if he was just waiting for the
BBC to spoon feed him,
he's never going to do it.
Also,
I think that having the stupid shows
that we have here in America,
like if you watch reality shows,
one of the things that you'll notice is
the anger that people have about these
shows,
the anger that to being forced fed this
fucking stupid shit,
but they're still watching it.
That anger sometimes that,
that,
that rejection of it almost in your soul
forces people to go explore other ideas
or it inspires people to go explore
other ideas.
Interesting muddle,
isn't it?
Frustrate the to deploy.
Just suddenly get so angry about the Ama
Guide,
soul crushing.
It was the building this culture that
you go seek out knowledge.
Maybe that there's something to it,
man,
because one time I was in my hotel room
and I was watching keeping up with the
Kardashians and uh,
you know,
look,
it was in between shows like,
you know,
just flipping through the channels and
it was on and it was like,
I'm shopping and I can't find what I
want to get.
This is so frustrating and my sister
won't stop bothering me.
And they're like texting each other and
it's so fucking mind numbing.
And somehow or another I'm sucked into
it like it's a tornado and it's carrying
away up into the sky and then I changed
the next channel and it's some biology
thing on crocodiles and it's instantly
fascinating and it's these people that
live on denial and this scientist who's
down there and he's studying these
crocodiles and you know,
there's the villagers who are worried
about these things eating them.
And then I'm thinking,
wow,
this is so fucking fascinating.
These people are living next to
dinosaurs.
I mean they have a real issue with
dinosaurs eating their family like.
Or You could watch these just simple
apes talk about shiny things and they'll
talk about shiny things and millions of
fucking people do,
but that the,
the anger of can't take this anymore.
And then you switched the channel or go
online.
I really think that does.
There's a yin and a Yang to the world,
the strongest case for the cadets that
compresses your very soul and existence
into such a small space that you out
into a world of ideas.
So that that's what's analogous to
California.
Because in California we have too much
sun.
We have so much sun that it doesn't
rain.
We need 11 trillion gallons of water
just to make up for the water that
didn't rain in the last three years.
It's a fucking disaster,
but if you lived in a place like Alaska
in the winter where there's no fucking
son at all and just looking for little
peaks in the clouds or those those days
in Portland where it's just 39 days in a
row,
there's no fucking son.
You just did crazy.
You can't take it anymore,
and then one day that sun is there and
you're like,
ah,
it's so beautiful.
Some May.
Whereas in La were like,
fucking son,
we're so tired of the sun.
We just.
People get used to shit.
I'm going to call it the Rogan muddle
when she's.
When she's just depressed.
Every rogue of muddle the broadcast in
the fuck out of them and they'll surely
at some point the cosmos.
Yes,
and then when it comes on and then they
get it.
Well not everyone.
There's gonna be some people that are
always going to be.
They're going to always gravitate
towards nonsense.
There's nothing you can do about that.
It's just we're so varied.
We're so the,
the spectrum of human beings from the
smartest to the dumbest is so wide.
There's no getting around that.
Life experiences,
genetics,
whatever causes it.
I don't know,
but there's just certain people that do
not give a fuck and they're going to
always be there,
but concentrating on them,
you know,
and,
and like it's profitable.
Like you could sell them shit.
It's a really good if you're,
if you're
in the business,
he days.
Uh,
I still,
you said Lee though I'm perhaps
optimistic of Va.
I think you could.
I think we can sell them.
It sounds almost them,
this group.
Some of them you could sell it.
I,
I still think you can sell ideas to
people.
I'm going to mystic about it.
Those people maybe not,
but there's a lot of fucking people.
There's $350 million people in this
country alone.
we underestimate people.
I think I,
I've,
I've rarely met someone who wasn't
interested in.
Let me take your sound.
Are you going to take home and bring it
around some dummies?
There's some fucking dummies out there.
a lot of smart folks like yourself.
You're hanging out at cern,
will a bunch of other physicists.
You're talking about black holes and
chelation effect.
You're right.
I've never been into the cafeteria at
certain.
Anyone who's not interested in asking
me,
man,
I hosted fear factor for six years and
I'm a cage fighting commentator.
There's dummIes out there,
there's a unfixable dummies and it's
probably not their fault,
but it's probably one of the greatest
pieces of evidence to do that.
Points towards natural selection and
point sorts of variability of life and
that human beings.
We very so strongly that in comparison
to other wild animals,
if you see wolves,
me and you see wolves that are slightly
larger and slightly more dominant and
wolves that are slightly smaller and
slightly more timid and they get pushed
out of the pack,
but they're all fucking wolves.
You See people and you see Brian Cox and
then you see kim kardashians.
I mean you guys are both on the same
timeline here.
You're both alive in this point in
history and one of you is talking about
fucking shoes and the other one is
trying to figure out what happened right
after the big bang and one of them has a
fuck load more people paying attention.
Brian cox and it ate you buddy.
It's the chick with the fake ass was
getting all the eyeballs.
Carl sagan is great book,
the demon haunted world.
I love that book.
I mean,
he makes the point that the thing is
these people,
everyone has a vote and rightly so.
We live in a democracy right now.
You mIght say,
well,
could we have some kInd of icu,
such threshold for the votes,
but therefore the direction of our
societies ease in principle in the hands
of everyone.
So,
so we can't just accept the fact that
you know,
well,
all right,
well one percent of the world's
population is going to pay attention to,
to reality and the rest of them are
going to pay attention to reality tv and
they're going to be,
we're going to be okay.
We're not going to be okay because the
99 percent will be on the web.
They're voting for that.
They have control and rightly so.
We live in a over the direction of our
countries.
So education is extremely important.
It is important for people to sit,
for us to try and make available the
great swathe of knowledge that we've
accumulated over the last.
We were absolutely in agreement about
that.
I just think that the open nature of the
internet enhances that more than stifles
it.
I think
there's only good.
I only see good.
I think I'm a big fan of old shit.
I love to go watch old television shows
and old,
um,
old movies and old especially old
standup comedy performances because
there's not just because it's sort of
like a time machine.
You're,
you're,
you're lookIng back at this moment
that's been captured,
which is absolutely fascinating to me.
But also the stark differences to the
obvious differences between culture then
and culture now between the awareness of
the people that like there's some movies
that were really good movies,
but if you try to wash them today,
you go,
oh,
who's that fucking dumb today?
Like no one is that dumb today.
It's hard.
Like the education level of the people
that are communicating in these movies,
the way they're there,
they view life is very obviously
different than the way we view life
today.
Like you could noT put father knows best
on television today because people
wouldn't fucking.
They're not like not enough.
Nope.
You gotta it's gotta go to a higher
frequency because human beings are very
different today than they were in 1950.
I think our culture is one of the
clearest influences.
There's some amazing stuff from 1950,
so amazing books that were written.
There's amazing films that were made,
but the reality is the culture has
shifted dramatically in the last 64
years.
there's no getting around that.
It's changing and I think having
something like the internet just pushes
that in a direction and the guidelines.
You who gets upset,
a guy like you who gets upset,
all these reality shows,
it's really just proof that that this is
what you're designed to do.
You're like designed to educate these
people that are annoying you in these
programs that are stupid.
That's actually just fuel.
It's just giving you more.
It's giving you an adversary.
It's giving you motivation to stop it
from happening.
I mean it's.
If everybody was going to college and
everybody was super educated and really
aware of the problems with plastic and
fossil fuels and boy,
what a weird world we live in,
probably nothing would ever get done.
Like the battle between the dummies and
the people like yourself is essential.
It's essential.
Then yang idea,
the thesis that the defining the motor
of civilization and human advancement is
irritation with dumb people.
I think it is.
I don't appreciate naps unless I work
out hard.
I don't appreciate vacations unless I'm
just exhausted.
I have to be exhausted with work to
appreciate vacations.
I must say.
It's one of the threads,
so maybe we started talking about
infinite monkey cage.
He's one of the threads through the
whole series is a slight annoyance that
we turned into into something that's
interesting.
Generates ideas,
pros,
I mean one of the.
We had a letter about the title,
the infinite monkey cage complaining and
they shouldn't catch monkeys.
It was cruel.
Crew is like an infinite.
It's an infinite cage.
It's me.
It's recently love room.
It's arguably the universe.
There's an infinite cage and then
another
less it came in.
I think it might have been a response.
So we'd send that back and they said
don't.
It's also support in this kind of
darwinian myth,
the darwinian myth that we're somehow
share a common ancestor with a monkey.
So how so?
And he said,
well,
there was an experiment done that
disproved all your nonsense,
like experiments.
We like evidence.
So This is really interesting.
What's the evidence?
So we read down and they said there was
an experiment done in a zoo in Alabama
or somewhere where they got 10 monkeys
and they gave them tight writers and
after a week all they done was shit on
them.
So the idea that an infinite number of
monkeys could write shakespeare and all
that,
it's like,
well there's a difference between 10
monkeys and an infinite number of
monkeys.
There's not,
you know,
10 is not very close to infinity and
it's just these complaints about the.
And we were my,
my friend robin into our co presented
where the.
He said,
he said it's not an incremental process,
this kind of infinite monkey thing.
It's not like if you have 100 monkeys
then eventually they'll produce a
leaflet and then if you have a thousand
they'll do maybe a book.
if you had 10,000
they'll do shakespeare.
And it's not really,
we mean it,
it's an infinite number of monkeys.
You'd need to type out the words.
But yeah,
we got a lot of.
We enjoy the complaint.
So we've got a lot from.
Yeah.
Got a lot of complaints from deepak
chopra.
Actually,
these days he's a silly version late,
isn't it?
Isn't that one of those things that,
that,
that.
That's like one of those expressions
that people always use it.
If you take an infinite number of
monkeys and given the typewriters,
they'll type out shakespeare's works of
shakespeare.
It's just,
is that true?
While it is true,
it's an infinite number of monkeys have
infinite number.
I think they're going to fail.
They're going to fuck it up.
No monkeys.
You don't know who's still wonky with
talking to me earlier about infinity,
you know,
but if you get an infinite number of
monkeys aren't there,
there's the same animal,
so the same exact animal.
They're going to type the exact works of
shakespeare that they will because
there's an infinite number of nuts.
Every possible combination of less
oppressive must happen.
Dan is true.
Would it happen?
What is the odds of it happening in the
exact same order of the works of
shakespeare isn't even calculus than
zero.
Less than zero,
but integrated in there so that if
you've got an infinite number of them
and then,
then you will get everything that can
possibly happen.
Will happen,
could you imagine if one monkey just
randomly,
they gave it a key,
you know what we're talking about the
entire universe,
right?
So we're talking about an infinite
number,
but what if they just get lucky as fuck
and give one monkey a typewriter and
this little dude just starts banging out
the entire works of shakespeare,
but he's still a monkey.
He's stIll like playing with his butt
and you know,
swInging around and having a good time.
He's not doing anything else other than
when they put them in front of this
keyboard.
He types out all the works of
shakespeare in exactly the right order,
the exact punctuatIon,
the exact spaces in between letters.
Well,
if the universe is infinite,
which it may
well be,
in fact,
there are many ways the universe can be
infinite,
then,
um,
that would happen because everything
that is in accord with the laws of
physics,
then it can happen.
And everything that can happen in an
infinite universe will happen because
the universe is formerly infinite.
So I contend,
and we'll probably get emails about.
I'm trying to think whether there's any
counter argument.
I don't think there is.
I contend that in an infinite universe,
even the most unlIkely possibility must
happen,
in fact formally an infinite number of
times,
so maybe shakespeare,
a monkey,
they just looked.
Maybe if someone's pet monkey,
we can imagine.
We can calculate it
when someone can do it online now
because there are how many letters are
there in shakespeare,
the complete works of shakespeare so you
can google that.
Someone will tell you and we know 26
possibilities and so off we go,
and so,
so how?
What's the probability?
What are the odds of randomly typing on
site writer,
let's say at one letter per second,
how long will it take and what are the
odds that your type out the complete
works of shakespeare?
That's a no number.
I don't know where my head,
but it can be calculated,
so that's my challenge to your viewers
and listeners sending that email.
Someone will do it.
There'll be someone working at mit or
something.
you can do it in five minutes.
that's an easy song
and then you'd have to calculate how
many monkeys start out with romeo and
juliet and then just start shitting on
their typewriter.
That I.
I know the answer to that is more than
the other ones and the first chapter.
Perfect.
And then just shit all over the place.
The last word.
The last single digit.
Well,
I bet every keystroke along the way
there's a monkey shitting on their
typewriter.
Like you get like the first paragraph.
Shit all over the place.
This guy got to the second paragraph.
Shit all over it.
Place to go back to having a monkey cage
complaint letter that proves that
darwin's wrong.
Hey,
that's the Logic that.
Yeah.
Can I just say that if someone doesn't
remember,
I just came into the podcast at that
point.
Yeah.
No he doesn't.
Yeah,
you can't cherry pick that quote.
yeah.
Just Brian Cox has nothing darwin's
wrong.
That'll be in the press.
There's a great website,
a twitter handle called take that darwin
where people that are educationally
challenged will question darwin's
theories like that.
My favorite one is,
you know,
people came from monkeys.
Monkeys are still around like dave
retweet that all day because someone
adjust that fundamental misunderstanding
of evolution that that really is,
you know,
you're going right where I'm going to
start maybe with the book.
The only wAy to truly test is to,
I think we'll really need to do is take
monkeys and give them psychedelic drugs.
We need to do this.
Someone needs to do this.
Didn't need to take an island where the
monkeys can't escape and give them
psychedelic drugs and leave them puzzles
and see what they figured out.
Why does that test anything doesn't.
I would just be fun
to watch.
There is a.
A guy named terrence mckenna who I'm a
huge fan of who had a a theory called
the stoned ape theory and he backed it
up,
allegedly remember who this is coming
from a with climate to logical data on
that time of the world that he believes
that the evolution of human beings,
the a big part of it,
the development of the human brain might
have come from them experimenting with
psychedelic mushrooms.
That as the rain forest receded into
grasslands,
animals were forced to try new foods out
because their habitat was changing and
they would climb down for these trees
and flip over these cow patties to get
bugs and worms and things along those
lines and that this time of the world,
it was very common to have these
psilocybin mushrooms growing all over
the place and that the monkeys that
would eat them,
he had a bunch of theories like
apparently it's been proven that in low
doses,
psilocybin increases visual acuity,
which would make you able to see things
better,
which would make you a better hunter
also makes you horny so it would make
people more likely to breed and that
would favor the people or the monkeys
rather.
The,
the subhuman primates,
whatever you call them,
that that went along that line.
What is it is one of them.
Will I be accepted theories about
hominid evolution is that is that
climate change played a key role and
actually there's in my life to say
receiving universe,
we.
We focused on a a theory which links the
climate change,
particularly in the rift valley because
we know that the big jumps in brain size
all occurred and enriched valley of
africa and it's quite remarkable
actually and that that broadly speaking,
accepted.
I think although I love argument with
anthropologists because the dates or his
spouse,
you know,
but it's broadly accepted that and it
seems that the big gym sitting in brain
size occurred at times when the soul
bates was most elliptical.
So the slb oscillates.
It becomes more elliptical than most
circular and there are many different
oscillations driven by gravitational
interaction with the planets like
jupiter in particular,
and it seems like when the ssl based
mostly elliptical the the rate of
climate change and the rift valley is
higher and more extreme and it seems to
be the case that this relatively strong
evidence for the case that when you get
these rapid times of climate change you
mentioned,
then you get increases in hominin brain
size and therefore increase in
intelligence is a big wig at one point
eight.
One point 8 million years ago,
which was a very big increase in the
number of species in the rift valley,
of which homo erectus was one of them,
which eventually led to us and a big a
big jump in brain size as well,
and this was at a time when there was
strong evidence for rapid climate change
in that,
in that region.
So that makes sense.
Like the adaptability of these animals
experimented with new food sources,
trying out new hunting methods.
They,
a lot of them changed from herbivore,
omnivore a lot of the primates that were
observed.
Right.
I get it.
That's where it gets controversial
when you look at the academic research
because the what,
so you the darwinian idea that.
So you get this pressure from climate
change,
but then what's the selection effect?
Because climaTe change happens over many
generations,
it doesn't happen over one generation.
so.
so the question is,
well,
what actually is doing the selecting?
What are we selecting for?
Why is this group I'm more likely to
breed and be more successful if it's
more intelligent?
So some people say,
well it's because we,
they were forced into groups,
so it's group dynamics is the fact that
you end up with bigger tribes,
you know,
hundreds of individuals cooperating
together and that's what's been selected
for and you need to be intelligent for
that.
Some people say as you said,
that it's more adaptability,
so maybe they have to learn to go
fishing or they have to learn to eat a
particular different crops and then
maybe that's.
So that's a big area of debate about
what might have been the,
the,
the selection pressure,
this precise selection pressure.
But it does seem pretty nAiled down that
climate change certainly in that region
of africa,
in Ethiopia and Tanzania and through the
rift valley had played a role in driving
us towards intelligence and essentially
shape scales.
Very small.
By the way.
I mean,
did you go back 4 million years and
you'll.
things like australopithecus are around.
We should basically outright
chimpanzees.
The brain is not much bigger than a
modern day chimp.
But then you go to 200,000
years ago and that's when homosapiens
first emerge and just over 200,000
years,
which is not very long ago,
and it's quite remarkable actually,
and that the modern theories,
they get spread out of africa that
60,000
years ago and they made it into europe
about 43,000
years ago also into north America and
south America only 15,000
years ago.
So it's a very,
quite a rapid spread.
And the fact that we've only been around
as a species for at most a quarter of a
million years,
a quarter of 1 million years is quite
remarkable.
I think.
Well,
when you think about what we've
accomplished,
I was flying into los angeles last night
and I was thinking if you could take the
pioneers that came from europe in the 17
and 18 hundreds.
The guys who were on those wagons with
the wooden wheels and they're pulling
them with horses across the country
trying to see what's over there.
If you could show them like,
hey man,
this is what's going to go down in 2015
hop on this plane.
Look out this window.
Oh,
look at that grid.
TheY would freak the fuck out.
They saw all the electricity.
That's the sky of los angeles,
in my opinion.
Los angeles.
More beautiful at night than any other
city because it's so spread out.
It's all lights as you're flying in.
It looks so science fiction.
You know,
I,
um,
recently interviewed the astronaut
charlie duke who landed on the moon,
the apollo astronauts.
And he said to me,
his father couldn't believe it because
he,
he was alive when the wright brothers
flew.
So he,
his father's spanned the time from the
wright brothers to an,
he was alive and then he,
some walked on the moon in one lifetime,
60 years.
Seventy years.
The real,
the real mind fuck is
with the creation of the plane to the
time someone dropped an atomic bomb from
the plane is less than 50 years.
Yeah.
And the nuclear physics,
we didn't know.
We didn't know there was an italian.
Rutherford discovered the atomic nucleus
in manchester in a.
Was it 1912 or so?
I should know.
But anyway,
17,
19,
12 and 13.
So he discovers the nucleus and within
30 years you have an atomic bomb,
didn't even know.
And,
and rutherford we actually asked at the
time,
he said,
it's the usual question we get as
physicists.
They say,
what's the use of this?
And uh,
and,
and rutherford said that there's no use
to it.
You said anyone who thinks that you
could use this as an energy source is
talking moonshine and within 30 or 40
years you have nuclear reactors
producing power and you have atomic
bombs.
A rapid rapid progress.
Well,
that's one thing that's been constant
about people and predicting the future.
And we've always got it wrong.
Oh,
well,
we,
we miss some of the rapid advances.
You know,
we talked about,
you know,
there's a computer on a phone here.
You're the fact that the modern
electronics is a single lifetime.
The transistor is what,
19 forties,
I think bell labs here in the us not
long ago.
You know that you go from that to this.
I mean we talked about the apollo.
I mean this is significantly more
powerful than anything that was
available in the world when apollo was
there.
The room rooms filled with computers at
nasa,
which we're nowhere near as powerful as
that.
It's amazing.
I mean that's those google glasses that
people are wearing is a sign of things
to come.
In my opinion,
they just stopped making them.
But there,
there's a new company that has like a
goggle.
It looks like a skiing goggle and it
allows you to move things in front of
you like a virtual desktop.
You can spin squares,
hold things in place,
throw things to the side,
and they disappear.
I mean,
we're,
we're going to get really,
really,
really weird within the next couple
decades.
I've actually seen some of that
technology is a company called magic
leap and I've been there in miami.
So you saw it in person.
What does it look really?
It does indeed.
Um,
you,
you can put three d objects into your
field of vision.
So how is that working?
So you've,
you've actually seen it.
I said,
dad,
you can't talk,
but I'll tell you that it works.
It's a remarkable thing about google.
It just bought the company.
Actually we,
yeah,
we played it.
We played some videos of it and we
couldn't figure out whether we were
watching a simulation.
We're watching what the future holds or
we're watching an actual demonstration
of that technology.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's going to be impressive.
I think.
And it's interesting what You said
because it brings the,
the,
the web this limited information into
your field of vision so you can
manipulate it.
And then there are questions about,
well,
what's real and what isn't and who,
who cares.
Anyway,
really.
And it's so interest.
Interesting.
Do you dabble at all in the theory of
some sort of an artificial world that we
live in,
these ideas of simulation do dabble in
that or is it just too much?
And actually,
I mean the,
the,
uh,
a
colleague of mine,
I mentioned,
there are some physicists who you think
that it's a possibility,
a strong possibility that we're living
in a simulation.
Um,
I mean it's,
you know,
it's speculative out their stuff,
but it's an attempt to explain some
properties of the universe that are,
that are interesting and unusual.
So,
so one of my favorite,
I think at the moment,
piece of cutting edge physics and
cosmology,
I should say,
the study of the universe,
the origin and evolution of the universe
is going through a revolution at the
moment and he's coming from data.
So it's coming from measurements of
things like the cosmic microwave
background radiation,
which is the oldest light in the
universe.
We're making it.
So just to rewind and say what that is.
And 380,000
years after the big bang,
the universe became transparent for the
first time to light.
And that's because it was,
it was cooling down as he would
expanding and cooling.
Then atoms formed,
it became cool enough for atoms to form.
And at that moment,
very,
very quickly,
uh,
the universe becomes transparent and so
photons of light can travel on through
the universe and they've been doing so
ever since.
And we can take a photograph of that.
And we have done with a series of
satellites,
the most recent of which is called
plank,
which is european satellite.
This up there.
So this is a picture of baby picture of
the universe as it was 380,000
years after the big bang,
and it's very beautiful picture,
but in explaining that a,
that's given support to theories called
inflationary cosmology theories.
So inflationary cosmology theories say
that before the universe was hot and
dense,
which we tend to call the big bang
before that,
the universe was still there and he was
doing something else which was an
exponential expansion.
So it was expanding exponentially fast,
way faster than the speed of light.
Then it stops and all the energy that
was causing that expansion gets dumped
into space,
heats it up,
and that's what we see as the particles
and energy today.
So those theories are kind of
interested,
but they also suggest there are.
There are things called eternal
inflation theories that say,
well how long did that period of
expansion go on for?
And does it all stop at one?
So does it stop in patches?
And if it stops in patches,
you get it stopped a little patch,
you'd get a big bang in the universe and
it starts another patch.
You get another big bang the universe,
so,
so these theories suggest perhaps there
were an infinite number possibly have a
big banks in inverted commerce,
which would mean there are an infinite
number of universities like ours and,
and they're beIng created now all the
time and they will continue to be
created ever.
so you get this fractal multiverse ever
growing exponentially fast.
And really bizarrely,
that those theories have some support
from the,
from the cosmic microwave background.
There are theories that explain the
structures we see.
I should just underline the fact that
this is speculative in a sentence,
but it,
but it's um,
but it's relatively mainstream that.
But one of my colleagues noticed,
some physicists have noticed is if you
were some kind of omnipotent deity
programmer and you want it to run what's
called a monte carlo simulation to say,
well,
I'll vary the strength of gravity in one
universe and vary the massive,
the electron and another one.
I'm very these physical constants and
see what happens then this is probably
this kind of thing you do.
This is what he would kind of look like
so that you can make an argument that
the universe in some sense looks like
one of these kinds of so called monte
carlo simulations because it gives you
the possibility of generating every
possible number of different ratio to
the strengths of the forces of nature
and all these things.
So I just have to emphasize this is way
out there way on the edge,
but it's fun.
And what is fun and interesting though
is it the wind all the way back,
the inflationary cosmology bit is,
is probably the most widely accepted
theory at the moment for how the
universe got to be the way it is and he
does lend itself to this idea that there
may be a multiverse and and it may be
that in,
in each different pocket universe if
you'd like.
You can have different physical
constants.
So most of them wouldn't allow life to
exist.
But some of them would say our universe
looks very fine tuned.
and if you look at it in a sense it
looks like that they belong with nature.
We're very slightly different.
You wouldn't get carbon,
for example,
produced In stars in large quantities,
which you need in order to the stars
die,
the carbon and the oxygen come out and
they rican lapse into another generation
of stars and solar systems and that's
how you get the heavy elements that make
up our bodies and so all those things
look you need.
You either try and find an explanation
for why the laws of nature of the way
they are or you.
You go to one of these multiverse
theories and say,
well actually goes back to what we
talked about earlier about the infinite
monkeys and me actually every
possibility occurs in nature and then we
shouldn't.
Shouldn't be surprised that we live in a
universe that's seems fine tuned for
life seems perfect for us to exist in
because every possible combination of
the laws of nature exists somewhere,
and this is where cosmology is at the
moment,
is this is genuine.
You could go onto the web and google it,
you'll find a thousand review papers on
what's called an inflationary cosmology
and it is cool and interest in actually.
Yeah,
it's beyond that.
It's,
it's very.
The idea of something being infinite and
not just infinite,
but infinite numbers of these infinite
things,
infinite numbers of infinite
universities,
these,
these theories exist.
So This idea of computer simulation,
the idea that the world we live in,
the universe we live in is a simulation.
That was the question that you asked
actually because we went on as
beautiful.
Don't change a thing.
You stay you.
The idea being that one day if human
beings continue to increase our
technological abilities,
one day we're like,
we're talking about this magic leap and
we're talking about the goggles that
allow you to see a virtual world.
We're going to,
if we don't ourselves up or get hit
by an asteroid,
we're going to come up with something
that is indistinguishable from the
reality that we see right now.
And when people start examining the
nature of the universe and they start
looking at the fractal nature of things
and looking at like what you were
saying,
that if you were going to be some
omnipotent deity that creates the
university,
probably do something like this,
like every single combination and throw
them out there.
So when we discover is is James Gates
that was the guy's name investigates,
investigates.
It was a guy who spoke to neil degrasse
tyson about string theory and that
they've found in string theory the
computer code that was created by humans
and like the 19 thirties they.
They figured this out and that this
actually exists in these codes in string
theory.
and his idea was that that somehow
another proves that there is some
evidence support that life.
The reality that we see right now is a
simulation.
Or it could be that which way more
likely that you're just discovering some
sort of code that the entire universe is
based on.
That.
When you look at things being fractal
and you look at the idea of there being
not just infinite expansion but infinite
contraction and that there is no
smallest point.
There's just smaller than we can
measure.
But when we talk about subatomic
particles and we talk about things being
like adam's being mostly air and then
you go deeper and deeper and you don't
know what the fuck is going on and
particles are blinking in and out of
existence and existing at the same time,
both moving and still la.
but could it be that you just got to
keep going?
We just can't see it.
Well,
the.
I mean the answer is,
I mean we still have three know what the
fuck's going on.
Some level of political.
If you look to the lhc,
the large hadron collider,
which is the place where we generate the
highest energy.
So it's the biggest microscope in the
world.
In essence,
we have an extremely good understanding
of the laws of physics at that level and
up to and including the discovery of the
higgs particle.
It's been proven.
Is that debate at all the higgs?
Because I remember there was some people
that were debating whether or not the
higgs boson bows on the.
There's a new,
the analytical data that we've
discovered and it has all the right
properties to be the.
The predicted standard model higgs,
politically,
please explain what that means.
Political.
It was predicted back in the sixties.
My pizza higgs,
this man,
his name,
and it's a.
The idea is basically the early on in
the expansion history of the universe,
so let's say less than a billionth of a
second,
after the big bang as the universe
cooled,
it went through something condensed out
into empty space.
So if people call a phase transition
over,
but it's analogous to a window pane on a
cold winter's day.
Die of cold winter days in la dia.
but if you were to get ice on a window,
it's analogous to say,
well,
it's a vapor condensing it into ice.
As you drop the temperature changes into
something else to into eyes.
So in the same way that the theory is
that as the universe cooled,
something condensed
out,
so empty space isn't empty.
It's full of higgs particles,
if you like,
or a higgs field.
So every bit.
So this means this space now,
not just space between the galaxies in
this room that every square meter over
this room is full of the higgs field.
And our fundamental particles,
the electrons,
let's say in our bodies,
interact with that higgs field and in
that process they acquire mass.
So it's the,
it's the mass generation mechanism is
why some particles are massive,
like electrons and quarks and some
things like photons are not massive.
They're massless and then travel through
the universe at the speed of light.
So that's the theory now that was
suggested and built a mathematically
essentially there's early evidence for
it at the time back in the sixties,
but over the years,
uh,
the theory called the standard model of
particle physics,
past all experimental tests.
So we got to the point where we thought,
right,
okay,
we will build a machine that will either
disprove or prove that theory and the
lhc is such a machine.
If that theory is correct,
which now seems to be it,
the prediction is you must find the
higgs particle at the lhc or some kind
of higgs particle.
And indeed we found it.
We,
as far as we can tell.
So that means that we found a new
particle.
It has the right mass as predicted in
the window that was predicted by the
theory.
It behaves in every way the theory
Predicts.
So now what we have to do is be
experimental physicists.
So the alex turns back on again in about
a month actually,
so it's been upgraded,
it's been fixed and it's done.
It's maintenance.
So we're going to make more higgs
particles now and that means we can make
more precision measurements and find out
whether it is the particle predicted by
peter higgs or maybe it's one of a
number of particles,
just possibly likely not now,
but it might be.
So it might be five of them,
for example,
which would suggest that theories called
supersymmetric theories are right.
So.
So we need to know exactly which
precisely had the thing behaves,
which is why we have more work to do,
but it looks like it's very sure,
very sure that it is a higgs particle
that you can just,
you can mess around and build isa
terrick theories that get around it,
but there is a new particle there.
There's no doubt about that.
And it looks like one of these things,
but that's the remarkable thing.
I think about it because it was wagner
when a great physicist wrote an essay
back in the sixties,
I think called the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics and the
physical sciences and the unreasonable
effectiveness is demonstrated by this
discovery because it really is a
mathematical prediction is we think
there's a new fundamental particle that
does the job of giving math to the other
particles and this is how it does it and
this is how it behaves and this is what
it will look like and this is what it
will do.
And then 50 years later you build the
biggest machine ever built 60 miles into
conference.
Most of it's in France,
a bit of it's in Switzerland,
tense scientists,
hundred and 50 countries.
You,
you accelerate.
Protons are the nuclei of hydrogen
around this thing at 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent.
The speed of light,
they go around the 16 miles thousand
times a second.
We can collide $600,
million of them together every second to
recreate the conditions that were
present less than a billionth of a
second after the universe began
photographing in the big east digital
cameras ever built.
The one I Work on called atlas is 40,
40 meters in diameter,
vast vast thing,
7,000
tons of digital camera in a cabin beside
st paul's cathedral underneath the
ground in Switzerland and you find it,
you find this guy,
but he's a higgs working with many of
the people predicted to exist 50 years
ago because he did some sums and so it's
a real.
It's real.
So the universe does behave like that.
There is a condensate in the vacuum.
It is a higgs condensate.
It does give mass to do the particles.
So it's a tremendous testament to the
power of human reasoning,
I think,
and it means that we understand physics.
It means that we.
That's one of the important things about
it.
It means that our,
our understanding of fundamental physics
is not horribly wrong at the moment.
It's,
it's,
it's good enough to predict something
like that,
which is a remarkable achievement that
is mind blowing.
that is truly,
truly mind blowing.
Do you know when peter higgs?
Actually,
so the day that the discovery was
announced at cern,
packed auditorium and peter was there
and a journalist went up to him
afterwards and just what I've said,
this is what happened.
This machine did a family thing and
said,
how do you feel?
Professor hagen?
And he said,
it's very nice to be right.
Sometimes
really understated british and yes he
is.
There you go.
That's exactly how a cup of tea american
would show up with a fur coat on
diamonds around his glasses.
We have a big pimp cane and then someone
had come up,
have given the nobel prize to beyonce
because that'd be grammys last night,
wasn't it?
Was it was.
It was.
It was in Kenya.
West wasn't.
It keeps jumping on stage.
Well,
he jumped on stage once,
right?
He didn't do it again last night.
Did he?
Apparently,
ginny almost have it go.
He said,
I can't be bothered,
so I just keep thinking part of the
problem.
You just want to talk about kanye west,
the middle of the.
One of the last discussions I called the
other guy jay zed called z zed.
That's a british thing.
People don't know like a zero.
Six is a type of corvette.
They call it zedo six.
So jason was copy of the large hadron
collider also figured out or or proved
proved cork.
Gluon plasma.
Yeah,
so that is explain that the
universe in the history of the universe,
so so way after the higgs mechanism
kicks in,
you get an.
You have a period when it's still too
hot for protons and neutrons to form the
building blocks of atomic nuclei or
protons and neutrons day.
So a proton is made of two up quarks.
Quarks and a damn clock and a neutron is
made a $2 and then up and then some of
the stuff in there,
glue gluons and things like that,
but what the universe was winter aphasia
and it was too hot for that to happen.
so you get this plasmid is see of the
free quarks and gluons and all these
things just before it gets cold enough
to condense into protons and neutrons
and we investigate that by colliding a
heavier things in protons together at
the lhc so we can do silver atoms or a
silver nuclei or lead nuclei and things
like that.
The lhc can do that and it produces this
fat a millionth of a second after the
big bang.
So quite a long time.
Quite a bit.
This is a lot has happened in that
relatively.
So we can do that as well and see how
that phase of the universe behaved and
that stuff is supposed to be just
immeasurably heavy.
Right?
oh,
the atomic nuclei.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at.
So it astrophysical example would be a
neutron star,
which is basically a big nucleus,
nuclear dense material.
The end point of a collapse star when
it's run out of fuel,
maybe it's not too big.
It's too big.
It'll turn into a black hole.
So neutron star would be a one and a
half times the mass of the sun.
Let's say something like that,
but it will be a radius of 10 miles,
so it would easily fit in the la
metropolitan area.
Right.
But it would have the mass of the sub or
greater.
So that's an atomic nucleus density.
That's how you can imagine it.
Something as massive as some compressing
something 10 miles across and we see
these things all over the years.
Neutron stars are fascinating things.
Someone online was explaining it.
Some physicists was explaining that if
you had this court glue on plasma and it
was the size of a sugar cube,
it was some ungodly amount of weight.
Yeah.
like he couldn't even imagine it.
You know,
mount everest,
you know,
that kind of who'd be like mount everest
can't quite enormous broke my brain,
be thinking about all our lady to
earlier all the mess our mass is in the
nuclei and if you've got all our nuclei
mining your nuclei and stuffed them
together into that density that,
you know,
it would be a grain of sand or something
less.
So you could.
I mean,
you think about the unit,
I mean the modern theories of the big
bang it talked about earlier,
these inflationary cosmology theories,
those suggest that the entire observable
universe,
which has now got $350 billion galaxies
in it,
was some point the size of a,
I dunno,
a baseball or less so,
so we imagine that we speak of in,
in modern physics,
we have theories to address the time
when the entire observable universe was
something that you could hold,
so you've got enough energy in there to
make $350,
galaxies each with 200 billion stars and
it's remarkable that we're not quite
there with the laws of physics,
but we're not far that.
Those are the kind of.
That's the physics we're doing at lhc.
Basically.
We're trying to explore the laws of
nature and seat,
find the laws of nature will describe
the universe when it was that hot and
that dense and we are quite close.
I say we were good from about a
billionth of a second after the big
bang.
Then that's where we have our theories
that talk about the higgs boson and
things,
and so we understand that very well.
Um,
so the,
the,
the challenge now is to get back beyond
that and that's where you,
that's where string theory attempts to
live,
which you mentioned earlier string
theory.
We don't know if it's right.
We have no evidence to that.
That is an approach to trying to
describe the universe before,
uh,
those times when our current laws work,
the idea of a birth and a death of a
universe trouble.
Some people,
the idea that we have sort of
artificially subscribed the idea that
this had to start somewhere and that it
may very well be an infinite expansion
and contraction like waves going in
waves going out.
The idea being that the entire universe
may one day get to a point where it
pulls down into itself and becomes one
event.
Horizon one infinite peace of mass and
then starts all over again.
Is that possible?
The current,
if you look at the,
how the universe is expanding at the
moment than it is accelerating in its
expansion.
So the measurements tell us that the
expansion rate itself is getting faster
and uh,
we have,
uh,
a name for that and we call it dark
energy.
And so the of older 65,
70 percent of the energy in the universe
appears to be taken up in,
in driving this increasingly fast
expansion.
And so that looks like if nothing
happens,
then that becomes dominant.
So,
so,
so it continues to accelerate and
expansion.
And in the end you get something that
looks like this inflationary period that
I said may,
may have existed before the universe was
hot and dense.
So it looks like.
So that looks like what's happening at
the moment.
So whether that can stop where,
whether there's something that can stop
it in the same way as it seems to have
stopped very early in the history by the
way.
And whether that's true,
nobody knows,
we don't know the mechanism,
but the measurements tellers have
distant.
Particularly looking at supernova in
distant galaxies.
And also actually from this cosmic
microwave background radiation.
I mentioned earlier that the detailed
modeling and measurements of that old
consistent and that the university is
accelerating in its expansion,
so that would suggest that it's not
going to rebound because it's
everything.
It's like a big rip scenario almost
where everything's accelerated.
That space time is stretching it a
faster and faster rate at the moment.
That seems to be what's happening,
so you feel that it's much more likely
that there are infinite numbers of these
things happening,
that there's not just one big bang that
creates this universe and we're watching
this universe expand,
but that there's infinite numbers of
these things that are happening at the
exact same time.
That said,
that's most speculative,
so,
so the waY that the inflation is
probably textbook.
Now you got some physicists that will
argue with it,
but broadly speaking,
I think many astrophysicists think the
inflation is the best theory we have
because it makes predictions that agree
with observation.
So it's.
It's the best theory in terms of making
the best predictions at the moment in
this is that exact suggested expansion.
Very fast,
super luminal faster than light
expansion.
That stops and the end point of that is
what we used to call the Big bang and
so,
so that's broadly speaking,
textbook stuff.
That's what you teach and undergraduate
Cosmology causes that.
Then some physicists argue that the
natural extension to those theories,
the theories called eternal inflation,
which are what you said where you said
this,
this exponential expansion of space time
is always going on and it stopped just
in little patches and that little patch
is where you generate a new pocKet
universe if you like,
of which ours is one example,
and you can have an infinite number of
those and they were being that they
would be being produced now and you can
asK the question,
how long has that been going on?
And the answer is nobody knows,
and there's a debate even amongst the
people who believe in those theories
about whether it could have gone on
forever or whether it would have started
in what a colleague of mine at durham,
carlos frank calls the mother of all big
bangs.
So was the mother of all bIg bangs that
set this process in motion.
And in that thing that got said,
that big fractal thing,
you get loads of little bit guys,
and the answer is this is cutting edge
stuff.
It's very exciting.
Um,
but so,
so I'd say just to be very precise,
the inflationary bit,
the simple bits which was first put
forward in the eighties actually by alan
guth and people like that in the us and
andre,
linda,
another one that looks right in the
sense that it matches data very well and
the consequences of it are argued about
an interactive areas of research at the
moment.
One of the things that
people were terrified of about the large
hadron collider is that in trying to
find the higgs that you might
accidentally create black holes,
little tiny one,
so it would just go eat and through the
earth,
like a,
like a little ping pong ball that's shot
through the entire planet that that's
idiots like me that thought that,
holy shit,
is it possible to create a big bang or
excuse me,
a black hole?
Is that,
is it possible theoretically to have
enough power?
Like if you don't have it right now with
the large hadron collider,
is it possible that a larger machine
will be created and human beings can
recreate a black hole?
Yes,
it's possible.
And it's possible if You have extra
dimensions in the universe.
Right?
So the thing is that,
so we need gravity's.
A very weak force is by far the weakest
of the four fundamental forces of nature
be billions and billions of times a
week.
And the other ones,
which you can tell because you can pick
up your phone,
even though the planet,
planet earth is trying to stop me doing
that,
and I can just resist the pull of
planet.
So gravity is very weak.
So that gives you a clue that you can
say,
well,
what energy?
How far do I have to go back in time?
If you like,
towards the big bang before it's so hot
that the,
that gravity is as strong as the other
forces.
The strength of the force is varies,
I should say,
with,
with energy.
So they changed so that.
And we've seen this behavior,
so so two of the forces,
so-called electromagnetism,
which is the most familiar on
electricity,
that one a and the weak nuclear force,
which is one of the forces that operates
in the atomic nucleus.
They are the same force.
They're manifestations of the same
force,
and we've seen this experimentally,
and in fact the higgs boson is part of
that process.
And so we've seen the energies that they
become the same force.
So the idea is the other force,
the strong nuclear force,
if you go to higher energies and
temperatures convergys and they'd have
some things called grand unified
theories,
and then gravity makes it a lethargic
way back and,
and unifies with them.
It's something called the planck energy,
which is immense.
The short timescales after the origin of
the universe have you on so very,
very hot,
so,
so way in excess of anything.
So if you just want to just create black
holes in a lab,
then the nike thing is you'd have to go
to those energies and there's nowhere in
the universe.
You'd never do it.
So you'd have a part accelerated the
side of the observable universe and they
wouldn't be big enough,
but if you allow extra dimensions in
space,
so you might imagine that we will live
in a three dimensional space and then
there's time as well as four dimensions
if you allow it to be five or six or 30.
Nothing to string theory that they keep
changing their mind,
but there's 13 now,
something like that,
and then what you can do is you can
arrange for that energy scale at which
gravity becomes important to to,
to to come up.
So the temperatures to drop so you can
arraign.
You can arrange in some contrived way to
get to the point where you could
possibly access gravity,
see gravity in action as it were in
particle accelerators,
at things as big as the lhc,
and in that case you would produce we
little black holes,
which would then evaporate away very
quickly.
We think through a process called
hawking radiation and they be.
They began.
So you can conceive of a way that you
could,
if given a big of a leap,
that there are extra dimensions in the
universe and given that they're
configured in the right way,
that you can imagine that you could do
it.
The the.
The interesting point though is that so
lhc is,
is it's a tremendous technological
achievement,
but it collides particles together,
energies that are just insignificant
compared to the energies that are
available in the universe to nature.
So cosmic rays,
for example,
hit the earth with energies far in
excess of those that we generated,
lhc.
So whatever physics she can conceivably
access of these parcels,
accelerators is already been access now
in the upper atmosphere of the planet
because the cosmic ray collisions are
immensely higher energy.
So so you can make little black holes
because they're extra dimensions in the
universe.
Then they are raining down on us.
Now they're here.
They get made because the,
the energies of the lhc is,
I said,
astrophysical processes all over the
universe,
way in excess way exceed those energies.
We were not very good at doing high
energy collisions compared to nature.
That's a supernova,
explosions and compared to all the and
cosmic rays because it cosmic ray
actually that was detected,
I think the highest energy one was the
had the energy of a professional tennis
player serve so hundred mile an hour
tennis ball.
Right?
And it's a single particle.
So imagine getting hit by a hundred mile
an hour.
Professional tennis players serve on the
back of their head,
their cosmic rays with that energy.
But the one particle of would be equal
to 100 miles an hour tennis ball.
So these are credible energies.
Way beyond any how many particles would
be in a tennis ball.
Oh,
it's a good question.
That.
So let's do some sort of thing.
So,
so I have a gander.
Rose number is what is it?
Six times 10 to the 23,
isn't it?
That's right.
So that,
that's the number of particles in the
number of atoms,
let's say in 12 grams of carbon.
So it solved the old of.
So tends to the 23.
Is it 10 to 24 is a million million,
million million,
right?
So that.
So a million,
million,
million particles would be what you'd
have in atoms or carbon you'd have in a.
You find me on the spot here on you if
that's what you'd have in about what?
Sixty,
60 grams of carbon or something like
that.
So you've asked to guess.
I'd say something like that.
And that's chemistry.
See I don't do chemistry,
but that's out there.
Just floating around and we got rid of
the galaxy.
Like when a hyper nova,
you still trying to do the math made?
Sure.
Because we live on the web.
I don't want to get it right.
I get older.
people do that all the time.
The show's all about wrong answers.
You're just talking.
It's not your field of study.
I understand,
but it should be really,
really good.
Chemistry.
I think chemistry or physics,
but bigger blogs.
I've watched a documentary once on hyper
novas that when they were first
discovering the gamma burst in the
galaxy,
they thought it was aliens having wars
with each other.
That was one of the.
One of the ideas that were being bandied
about.
Great.
I mean,
people do legitimately look for
signatures from alien civilizations like
that sort of.
Yeah,
But it's kinda mad people who do it,
but they're actually,
you can do.
There are papers written about because
you might say what would the signature
of a,
of an interstellar star looked like?
Presumably be a matter and antimatter
drive or something like that.
So you get these very Clear signatures
of matter and antimatter annihilation
that we know about because we do that,
that particular photons,
gamma rays with particular energies and
so you can,
you can actually say,
well shall we have a look?
What would it look like if we saw an
interstellar civilization and interspace
fair in civilization?
Could we detect the signatures?
So there's a bit of work done on that
and we don't see any.
We don't see any evidence for anything.
Well,
when you see someone like the people
that run seti search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and
they're always like asking for funding
and like,
you know,
we need more funding.
We have to figure this out.
and one day,
what if we shut down?
And then the signal comes like,
that seems to me to be like one of the
biggest,
like hail mary wishes,
like hoping that you're going to find a
radio signal from a galaxy far,
far away that has intelligent life.
I mean our galaxy.
Well,
it's interesting though that if you ask
astronomers,
so you say what's the probability of
civilization has been out there.
Then they will point,
for example,
to the new data from the capitalist
space telescope which tells us that
there are probably around 20 billion
earth like planets in the milky way
galaxy in the sense that they're small
rocky planets in what's called the
habitable zone around stars.
The goldIlocks main sequence.
Stars like the earth,
like the sun.
So,
so 20 billion.
So maybe one in 10 stars in the sky has
an earth like planets around it
potentially.
So that's a lot.
So you think 20 billion devices,
surely life must have a on on some of
those.
The answer is probably yes.
I suspect.
I suspect we'll,
we'll,
we may find life on mars in the next 10
years,
but it will be microbes.
So the question then becomes,
well,
how likely is it for simple life if it
arises to make its way into a
civilization?
And that's where the biologists come in
and kind of calm the astronomers down
and say,
well,
you might think there are lots of places
for life we would agree,
but on earth it took three point 8
billion years to go from the origin of
life to a civilization which is about a
third of the age of the universe,
give or take.
So you had to have an unbroken,
stable line of life.
the,
that,
um,
that evolves in the,
in the right way as it were to.
So first of all,
it gets complex.
I mean,
it took.
There's a thing called the cambrian
explosion in the history of life on
earth,
which was about 550 million years ago or
so,
we sounds like a long time.
But for 3 billion years before that,
there was nothing that we would Call
complex single celled organisms doing
some clever Stuff like photosynthesis,
but not much.
and then suddenly you get a big jump in
the oxygen content.
Of the atmosphere on earth,
which was to do with photosynthesis and
some geology in play with it.
That's how the oxygen gets into the
atmosphere and then you get a big jump
and you get complex life emerging and
then pretty quickly,
you know,
half a billion years or so,
you go from complex things to to
civilization.
But even then you think about homo
sapien.
As we mentioneD earlier,
they only arose 200,000
years ago.
So for,
for the vast majority of the history of
life on earth,
that has been nothing that could do
anything clever in the sense of
thinking,
building spacecraft and radio
telescopes.
So,
so does it really legitimate debate
about whether the undoubted increase in.
We know now that there are homes for
life out there in the milky way.
They're very common.
We know that,
but we don't know is the probability
that life will emerge in the first
place.
And secondly,
the probabIlity that will be turned into
a civilization.
And I think that's very low.
So I think like I think the ability,
if I guessed,
I would say the probability that life
will emerge given the right conditions
is very high and what one piece of
evidence you could put forward to that
is that it did appear to emerge on earth
as soon as he could after the formation
of the earth and the oceans.
So you get life.
But then it took a long time on earth.
So you mIght say,
well the,
you know,
the provost of it doing anything
intelligent and interesting,
quite low,
maybe less than one in 20 billion,
in which case you.
We ended up being the only civilization
in the milky way at the moment.
It is possible.
You can make the argument and my
experience is academic biologists tend
to be on the cautious side and an
astronomist tend to be on the optimistic
side.
It's all relative though,
isn't it?
Because even if we are only one out of
this entire milky way galaxy,
you still believe that it's possible for
an infinite number of monkeys to create
the works of shakespeare.
So really look at the entire.
Yeah,
because they have to.
We did that with remember,
but if you look at the entire universe
than the idea of there being not just a
life form like human beings,
but the exact same life form is not just
once but an infinite number of times in
the universe.
That's the universe.
I'm sure.
I mean there are 350 billion galaxies in
the observable universe,
so it would be surely there are
civilizations out there and more
advanced as well.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
I'm sure that's the shore and it has to
be the case in an infinite universe as
you say,
but it confined ourselves to the milky
way,
which is really the only place we have
any hope of exploring or contacting
anyone will never contacted anyone.
Even in the andromeda galaxy.
Two point 2 million light years away,
but we won't.
We won't,
but.
But the milky way,
if there's someone there,
we could at least aspire to contact
them,
so it's worth the effort to listen.
We don't spend much money on it.
It's we're spending too little on the.
I think it would be a tremendous
discovery if we made it as far as
something like that.
It's worth listening because you know,
when he started back with Frank Drake
and carl sagan and others back in the
sixties,
then they are.
No planets have been discovered beyond
the,
beyond the solar system numb.
So you the only planet we knew our
planets now,
as I said,
we've discovered thousands of planets
confirm discoveries and the statistics
tell you there are billions of them out
there.
So virtually every style probably has a
planetary system.
So,
so the,
the statistics have gone in the favor of
seti from the astronomical perspective.
But as I say,
you've also got to have the time to make
things like us,
uh,
you know,
and that,
that's a torturous process.
There's no inevitability to evolution.
I think it's not,
it's not,
uh,
not to be seen as some march to
complexity.
Evolution is,
it's,
it,
it does.
What it does is single celled organisms
were very,
very good at just surviving and getting
on with it for,
over,
for most of the history of life on
earth.
So it may be that complex,
multicellular life is kind of a just an
aberration,
really.
It's just a bit of a lucky accident.
So it's all really just perspective when
you think about it because there's,
even though there is enormous galaxy,
relatively speaking,
it's one tiny on that big little thing
in comparison to the rest of the
universe.
So even if we could find something out
there,
the likelihood of it being as advanced
as us are very small,
but it's just a matter of how far we can
reach or how far we can see.
I w I wouldn't go there.
NobodY knows it.
The what,
what people do now I think is that the
milky way is probably the boundary of
our aspirations.
It's for this generation or forever.
I think so what if we live a 100,000
years in public?
Keep the galaxies are hundred thousand
light years across the $200 million star
systems in it.
It's big,
it's too big it.
But that,
that's not.
So you could just about perhaps conceive
in the far future of beginning to spread
out into the milky way.
You could conceive of that,
um,
it given hundreds thousands of years,
right?
But then if you then you go,
well,
where's the next galaxy andromeda to
over 2 million light years away.
So the idea that you would get across a
distance of 2 million light years with
any conceivable technology is to me
probably.
I mean,
it takes light a light beam to 2 million
years.
So if you want to talk to someone in
andromeda,
you,
it will take 200,
2 million years to get a message out
there and 2 million years to get it
back.
So there's a full million round trip.
That's the nearest galaxy.
It's big,
right?
but it's so,
so you can imagine possibly the milky
way.
It's some chance if there are other
civilizations there talking to them.
But I think beyond that,
I just cannot conceive of how it will be
done.
Is this relative though a perspective to
the single celled organisms that existed
billions of years ago in comparison to
us?
Do we really think that we're the end
all be all?
And this is the last stop on the road to
evolution isn't impossible that we get
so advanced if we lIve to be another
billion years that we Can all these
ideas that we have in oUr head about the
laws of space and time and the,
the,
what particle physicists are trying to
figure out and what string theorists are
prescribing as far as,
you know,
15 different dimensions that we just
send it to them.
I know that that's pretty unfair to
them,
but I want to get into that because I
don't understand string theory.
No,
I don't know,
but I understand what you're saying.
Either my.
But my idea is that if we continue to go
on the same path,
I mean isn't it possible that we will
achieve some unfathomable level of
technological proficiency or have
control over matter or have or have an
understanding of the universe.
It's such a deep level that we can
violate all these things that we now
consider laws.
Like the laws of.
Yeah.
So the laws would have to be
approximation as to some deeper laws.
They're the einstein's theories of
relativity.
The best theories we have at the moment
to have space and time,
space time,
thank god for einstein and well it
wasn't general relativity actually 100
years old this year.
So that is,
it's amazing and I'm so the,
the speed of light as a,
as a fundamental part of the structure
of space and time actually is central to
that theory.
It's actually the thing that protects
and cause and effect.
So it protects if you like,
the past from the present and the
future.
So it,
it's built in in a very fundamental way
to that theory.
So you are right,
it's in principle that.
And it's a speed limit in that theory,
by the way.
And by the way,
there are strange things happened as you
approach the speed of light.
For example,
the theory says that time slows down
thing that's traveling relative to us.
So if someone there,
the number I know is the number for the
protons in the lhc.
So the protons go 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent.
The speed of light at that.
So imagine one of those flying pastors
now and you imagine it at a watch for
it,
suddenly the watch and you'd see it's
what past 7,000
times more slowly our watch it and it
would live 7,000
times more slowly than those.
So conversely,
if it was watching us,
um,
it,
that it would see the same effect.
So you can,
so you can move through time at
different rates,
essentially united starting this theory
that the faster you go relative to
somebody else,
the slower your watch ticks.
I got an idea.
We combine your world and the
kardashians and we shoot them in a space
of the speed of light and they don't age
well.
That's exactly right.
So exactly what you said.
The cool thing about.
That's what I was going to say.
The thing about relativity is if you go
at the speed of light,
you don't age,
no time passes.
And that kind of pointed.
You can't go at the speed of light
unless you're massless.
But that's kind of tough.
But he'd be a message.
You have to have you ever seen her ass?
Good luck making that thing massless
well,
exactly.
It's so be limited to travel below the
speed of light,
not just you.
even if she only weighed only one gram
in mass,
she's such a lot more than that.
Plus that's not a very aerodynamic
object either.
So we're launching that sucker.
Oh,
that's right.
It wouldn't matter in space because it's
a vacuum.
So you're all right today.
We're dynamics still.
So it's a fundamental thing.
So.
So if you,
if you're going at that fundamental
speed,
there's no time,
there's no distance.
Actually there all the distances shrink
to zero.
So it's a,
it's a long dress aids.
It's a fundamental part of the structure
of space and time.
So it's always been possible.
So you would need a different theory.
So it's literally impossible change
theory to go at the speed of light.
Unless you're massless engage,
you have to go at the speed of light.
Ken,
could you go just under the speed of
light and then time would just slowed
down so it wouldn't,
you wouldn't,
it wouldn't stop,
but it would slow drastically.
Yeah.
So as I said,
99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent gives you a factor of
7,000.
Now here's the question,
if you somehow or another we're able to
go 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent of the speed of light.
What would happen in your perspective as
far as time would?
Would time,
normal rate and their normal rate.
Yeah.
So you would age at a normal rate in
your perspective?
Yes.
But back home,
like if you came back around,
if you went out into space and you went
10 years at the speed of light and you
know,
you,
you came back,
everything would change,
but you'd be exactly the same.
Yes.
What would change for you though?
Something has to change.
So if the distances.
So if you travel.
So the other thing is let's talk about
the protons in the lhc again.
So they're their,
they're their times past in 7,000
signs more slowly from the perspective
of someone stood on the ground watching
them go round,
but from their perspective,
time's going at the same rate,
but something must change.
So what is it?
The distance.
So the lhc is no longer 16 miles in
circumference,
it's about now I know the number in
metric,
so it's four meters,
so that's what is that in three feet or
meters,
like three point zero feet.
Twelve feet?
Yeah.
So it's titled feet,
so it's squashes and so distance is
shrink from the perspective of the
protons,
so time passes at the same rate that the
normal rate for them for on their watch,
but the distances seem to seem to shrink
or do shrink not seem to.
They do deep.
Are you concerned at all about
artificial life?
Are you concerned at all about the
creation,
the inevitable creation of something
that in some way replicates independent
thought and acts on its own accord?
I always wonder if human beings are in
some sort of a sense a technological
caterpillar that's becoming a butterfly
and we just don't realize it in all of
our work.
If you look at one of the things that
human beings are absolutely fascinated
with,
whether or not it benefits us or not,
we're fascinated with technological
innovation.
What we want faster computers,
even if we don't even have applications
for them,
we want cars that goes zero to 60 in two
seconds.
We want everything to go quicker and
better and we we,
we don't get satisfied.
Nobody ever looks
at computers and goes,
we're good,
we're good.
We don't need a bigger laptop.
We don't need a stronger hard drive.
Everything seemed fine.
Let's stop innovating on computers and
move towards cancer research or no,
we will never.
We're never going to stop.
And I always wonder if what?
Whatever drives us.
What if,
what if is similar in some way to
caterpillar building a cocoon,
get about to give birth to this new
thing.
Totally unaware and that artificial life
that our work with,
whether it's code or whether it's
electronics or whether it's three d
printing,
a combination of all those technologies
coming together to create some new form
of life and we don't think of life being
possible in an electronic sense because
we think of life as being cells and
blood and all the things that we are,
but is it possible that we might just be
building the next thing that you know,
we look at,
well,
we've only been alive for 200,000
years.
Yeah,
but we might be shitting out the new
version of life with our constant
fascination with materialism.
I mean,
what is materialism ultimately,
if not a push for innovation and
technology?
A big part of what materialism is,
is keeping up with the jones' is getting
the latest and greatest.
Look at this.
This guy has got a new tv.
It sees your fucking brain.
You know,
it looks through your soul.
You could play back your history.
You know it,
it gets a fingerprint it.
You read it,
it takes your dna and it shows you what
your ancestors were doing.
Two billion years ago,
I mean,
well there's another aspects
of r and d besides consumerism,
isn't that the increased life
expectancy,
decreased child mortality,
although of great things too.
But I agree with you.
I agree with you.
I don't see any reason why I'm ai is in
principle not possible because I think
that although you know the research,
we don't understand the brain,
but I think it must,
it must be an object that operates in
accord with the laws of physics.
He,
I,
I strongly suspect that our conscious
experience is emergent,
so it emerges.
So there's a,
there's an algorithm there.
Very complex algorithm,
but I don't see why it can't be
simulated in a sufficiently powerful
computer in principle.
So I don't see why you can't have a
conscious competer.
I don't personally see why you can't.
Therefore,
if that's true,
then you can given them and as you say,
the,
the rate of increase in computing power.
Is it rapid?
We're not there yet.
There is a project in,
in europe are very big project to build
a,
a brain simulator.
It's a long way off and you're talking
about billions of dollars,
but I'm at the moment,
you know,
as you say that 40 years ago,
a billion dollars when you vote,
you have an iphone,
so.
So yeah,
I,
I agree with you,
and actually energy said three d
printers a essentially seem to be the
first step on the road to self
replicating machine.
So you've the computing power that can
be intelligent and you've got a means of
it being a replicator.
Then I don't see why you can't build ais
that replicate.
And actually going back to the cosmology
for a minute,
one of the arguments against the
existence of civilizations,
more advanced civilizations,
the nose in the milky way is that they
would have done that.
And this is an argument from a
mathematician called paul nyman and also
a physicist called fermi.
It's called the fermi paradox.
That let's assume that let's,
let's fast forward a ge said,
let's fastforward our civilization.
Ten thousand years,
leT's say blink of an eye.
Let's see.
We'Ve only been around for.
We've been around for less than that as
a civilization.
Let's aa 10,000.
What are we going to look like?
Will we have built self replicating ais?
yeah.
Unless there's some reason in principle
why you count.
So what do you do?
You send those out there replicators.
They can go to asteroids.
Mine print three d print a version of
themselves,
go off again.
they exponentiate they can crawl over
the galaxy,
exploring for free.
They send them out,
we see no evidence of those things.
And they called von neumann machines.
So it's one of the great.
You can either say that there's
something in principle that stops you
doing it.
So actually there is something special
about intelligence and you just can't
with some reason why you can't build a
computer that's artificially
intelligent.
I don't see why that would be the case.
Oh,
you could argue you can't build the self
replicating,
but you can because we are.
We're replicators and we operate in
accord with the laws of physics.
So there.
So there's a replicated or the reason we
don't see them is because there aren't
any civilizations that ever got to that
level in the milky way.
So we're the tip of the spear.
No one what?
We can't.
We couldn't be the first.
It's very difficult to see how we could
be the first.
Someone has to be the first.
Why can't it be us?
But because.
Because the milky way has been around
for the age of the universal use.
Say don't you know the earth is 6,000
years old,
do you not go on with the [inaudible]
side?
So the timescales,
we're talking billions of years really
into planets,
billions of years,
but it has to happen in a one time was
somewhere and then sudden.
And if you get one wave of these ais
away into space,
then you can show using computer models
with realistic assumptions about rocky
power and things like that.
you can cover the galaxy in on
timescales of much less than a billion
years.
Actually million years less than that.
So it's a.
You can shoW that you can cover the
galaxy and your von neumann probes.
You're replicators in,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of years.
Let's say a million,
2 million,
3 million,
10 million.
It doesn't matter because we've got
billions of years and yet we see no
evidence of them,
so,
so what are we to make of that?
Either there's something wrong with our
arguments that we're putting forward
that actually you can't build self
replicating intelligent robots.
I don't see why not,
but maybe there's something wrong with
that.
Or really civilizations are so rare that
as you say,
we are the first to get to that level,
but that's interesting,
isn't it?
That that will be an interesting.
I always think I'm a segue sentence to
this,
so imagine we're the only civilization
in the galaxy.
What a tremendous responsibility there
is honors.
Imagine what that knowledge should do to
our political processes.
The way that we think about ourselves,
the way that we get on together.
imagine how ridiculous it is to divide
our little world or into countries and
another little war every now and again,
important nuclear missiles at each
other,
if in fact there's nowhere else in the
milky way galaxy where anybody thinks
anybody can look at the styles and think
about and have these conversations.
What a ridiculous way to behave.
So I think the cosmology is gives a
perspective which is not necessarily
need to be humbling,
it is humbling and that's perhaps a good
thing,
but it doesn't need.
You don't need to be depressed about it.
It could be quite elating you say,
well,
with what we are according to the
evidence and the data at the moment is
almost indescribably special.
Our,
our tininess,
our potential uniqueness,
our insignificance in a cosmic scale
actually makes us special because we're
the only place.
And so.
So these,
these ideas are worth pursuing I think
because they make you think about these
issues,
doesn't it also point to our ego that we
think that our biological processes any
more important than the exploding sons
that are required to create carbon life
in the first place or,
or any of the processes of the universe.
The answer that I think is that you're
right,
that in a,
in a,
in a signal,
in a completely logical sense,
we no more important or less important
than the stars themselves.
You're right,
which is natural objects.
But I would counter by saying that
people look for meaning in the universe.
People like to look for meaning gets
this one thing that we've done since we
began to look at the stars.
The universe means something to me,
doesn't it?
It does.
Meaning exists because it means
something to us.
So we know that it would be ridiculous
to say the university is meaningless.
It means something in my relatively our
families,
we have loved ones,
etc.
So the fact that that meaning might be
emergent,
it might appear from the laws of nature
and it is almost certainly transient.
Unless we build these self replicating
machines,
we will.
We're not going to last forever as a
civilization probably.
so that to me,
that doesn't in any way water down the
significance of it.
So I think again,
cosmology can be,
can be a poWerful,
uh,
aid to philosophical thoughts in this
sense because you have to accept that
there's meaning in the universe because
it means something to us.
I don't see why it has to be eternal.
I don't see why there was that meaning,
does it imply purpose?
I don't think there's any purpose to the
universe brings any point to our
existence.
But the fact that we exist at all is
worth celebrating.
You don't need to add anything else.
In fact,
you almost did it to me.
You're devalued it.
So why would you?
This is remarkable.
We emerged a single celled organisms
probably before that.
We
emerged some chemical reactions in in
hydrothermal vents,
probably down in the deep primordial
oceans of ancient earth and over three
point 8 billion years,
we've come to the point where we can sit
and think about the styles and have
conversations like this.
Is that not enough?
can we just leave it there?
Why does it have to be a point?
There isn't a point.
I don't think it's appalling to that,
but it's worth celebrating.
Well,
it certainly is to us.
To us,
it's amazing,
but you know,
in a lot of ways isn't looking
throughout the incredible cosmos for
signs of life,
like looking in a sea of parked mercedes
benz for dust,
like one of these cars must be fucking
dusty.
JuSt cleaned them.
I'm going to find it.
And you're ignoring the incredible
mechanisms that are in front of you.
There's an amazing technology.
antilock brakes.
Fucking 12 inch computer screens that
ended up gauges anymore.
The cars drive for you,
they steer for you,
they break for you,
and we're like,
one of these motherfuckers has dust on
it just like us.
These planets,
and we talked about our planet being
four point 6 billion years.
the universe is 13 point eight.
We're looking for things that live 100
years were like just got to be one out
there that sing songs somewhere.
There's a better rapper than jay zed and
he's out there in the universe.
We've got to find him.
We to find him.
This is a search and we're ignoring
steroids,
gamma rays and better rap.
We should read,
write and masses and reasons.
Again though,
it doesn't take anything away from the
fascination of just,
you know,
one of the beautiful things about being
a human being is that we think about
these things and that we can communicate
and that you getting on this podcast
can.
You're planting all these seeds in
people's minds that are making them
consider these thoughts and now it
spreads.
And that's.
That's one of the most fascInating
things about the idea of intelligence is
that intelligence begets intelligence.
Intelligence sort of stimulates other
intelligent.
It's not simply,
I mean,
I think one of the reasons why you love
educating is like,
you know,
how important this is for you and you
want,
you've seen the spark and people's eyes
when you explain these things to them
and you realize that that person might
spread that spark somewhere else and
this is really what this process is
about in the first place,
but it has meaning to us.
But in the grand scheme of things,
we're just exporting kardashians through
the universe.
Well,
we could make it stop by exploiting.
They could see the resistance of
exploring the kardashians makes people,
you know,
the new version of cosmos with neil
degrasse tyson bag that gets out there
to which said,
that makes me optimistic actually,
because I wouldn't have either.
I think it's all together.
He'd done
again.
You know,
I,
I have to because carl sagan,
great hero of mine.
I mean,
the fact that it would be doing them on
the fox in a network,
you know,
a 13 episodes of it is.
It is,
it is.
There are people out there who want to
do it.
Yeah.
Are most certainly and more so now than
I think ever before and more so in the
future.
I think even though there is evidence
that people are dumb as shit,
there's still more evidence that people
were super curious.
I think it's just a,
it's a numbers thing and if you spoon
feed people the same thing over and over
again,
like you know,
there's the argument for a limited
network,
especially american style or you could
just sort of do it the bbc way,
but the bbc way is beautiful and that
sort of sandwiches,
these brilliant shows in between other
shows like,
but not enough.
There's not enough room.
There's too many things out there now
there's,
you only have 24 hours in a day.
There's no fucking way you're going to
have enough programming.
You just.
Unless you have an infinite number of
bbcs like he,
you,
you can't.
There's just too much shit going on.
The world is too vast and that's not
discounting anything that the bbc has
ever done because one of my favorite
networks,
I'm like,
I have this Congo series that I've
probably watched a dozen times about the
bbc,
which is one of the most fascinating
documentary documentaries,
not just on a particular area of the
world,
but on life itself.
Adapting,
which is like the primary sort of theme
to that,
to that documentary where they're
talking about these,
these parts of the world that were
changed really rapidly over a period of
a couple thousand years where we used to
be planes and then it became these dense
rain forest and there's all these
animals that are sort of trapped in this
world like rhinos and plains animals.
And Were.
There was a piece on these,
um,
these type of antelope color diker that
swims underwater a 100 yards.
They can fucking swim.
They eat fish.
I mean,
it's craziness if swimming and swimming
as well,
it's related to an antelope.
but the idea is that you're talking
about a very short period of time,
a couple thousand years.
That's had this rapid amount of change.
These animals have had to adapt.
That is very strange.
New environment.
I think the,
the,
uh,
inability of some people to understand
that evolution and therefore react
against it.
It's all actually just,
just religiously motivated.
Most of it is,
but some of it isn't.
I think there's also a lack of
understanding of the timescales involved
and how fast animals can adapt and
change.
And what a powerful sieve,
if you like evolution is you can see it
richard dawkins often,
right when he's writing beautifully
about these things,
writes about and look at domestic dogs
and look how quickly the,
the,
the wolf got turned into these sort of
ready for poodles to german shepherds to
whatever It is.
All those things that now that selection
by humans,
right?
So we're selecting particular traits,
but the environment and the interaction
with other species is as powerful as
that.
It's as efficient as that.
It's the environment is a very powerful
selector of,
of traits.
Then so you can see that evolution
happens quickly.
Speciation happens quickly.
They're not quite with the dogs.
They still the same species,
but you can see how given a bit of time
you're going to get the poodles and keep
going on that line and get the wolves
and keep going on that line and
eventually you're going to get things
that look so different that if you
separate them and don't let them into
breed that you're going to end up with
something that can't breed with that
anymore and that's kind of the
definition of a new space is one of the
definitions of a new species.
So you can see how It can happen,
but I think one of the problems is the
timescales are not understood.
When you talk about thousands of years,
that's quite a long time.
Ten thousand years,
a long time,
200,000
years.
You go back that long and we didn't
exist as a species.
We weren't there so.
So,
you know,
100,000
years Is a hell of a long time.
Yeah.
Too,
too long too.
I think in our mind to process like we
can kind of process a lifetime,
you know,
we can process birth to a hundred years
while he lived to be 100.
Wow.
A lot of what?
A lot of things that guy must've seen.
But to process 100 of those.
Yeah,
100 hundreds.
How about a thousand?
How about 100,000?
Uh,
yeah,
It's,
it's just too much going on.
There's too much change that a long
time.
Do you subscribe to the idea,
and I've heard this debated about that
human intelligence may be in some form
exponential and that all the knowledge
that people have acquIred mean obviously
not like in a physical sense like
you're,
you're not born with an understanding of
math and language and all these things
are learned,
but that intelligence may somehow
another be not just passed on from
generation to generation,
but enhanced by life's experiences and
that the genes that are transmitted from
you to your children may be in fact more
powerful than the genes you were given
and that as you've lived your life and
acquired information and knowledge and
understanding and whatever,
whatever intelligence means,
you know,
whatever sort of intangible idea
intelligence truly is,
but that this mind power,
this,
this accumulation over the 200,000
years that human beings have existed and
people breeding and getting to this
point,
that this might exponentially be growing
and expanding.
Is that,
is that in any way possible that we're,
I,
I'm not an expert on genetics?
I don't think so.
I don't think there's any evidence as
far as I know that our iq average iq to
change much over the last few hundred
years,
certainly.
Um,
so.
So as far as I know,
that's not the way that it works.
There's the you need,
I think some kind of selector that would
say you'd have to take the most
intelligent levels by some measure,
let's say.
And,
and have them be more successful at
producing offspring than the people who
are less intelligent.
You'd have to do,
but isn't it?
You need some mechanism.
Why haven't they done like those do the
sperm banks were really super
intelligent people and like the kids
that come out of it or smartest shit.
Oh well that I could imagine that might
be true.
I think the correct answer
scientifically,
if you don't know the link between,
we don't know enough about the genetics
and the genome,
the human genome to say which bits are
producing brain power.
If research they.
Well,
what is it that you know,
which genes are really intelligent gene
or set of genes and I think that that's
not known I think is the right thing to
say,
but I emphasize it's not my field,
but it must have something to ponder.
When you think about evolution,
you think about genetic knowledge and
that the like certain things that I
would perhaps argue with that the idea
that.
I know there's some interest in this,
but I think that the standard answer is
that the,
the knowledge let's say,
so I become educated that,
that I think the standard answer is that
that would not have any impact on the
jeans that I passed to my offspring.
I don't think there's any known
mechanism to,
to have knowledge in imprinted,
so back into your genetic code such that
it can be sent onto your thing,
but you know,
you may have seen otherwise.
I,
I'm not aware of any research.
It's hard to like look into a kid's head
and find out exactly where all the
information is coming from.
Right?
Yeah.
But I don't think there's a known.
Well,
there isn't a known a known.
Was that just something we have to
tri caster just freeze up on us.
People at home right now are freaking
the fuck out.
We were just about to get to the bottom
of this.
I'm instincts like humans have certain
instincts,
right?
Like there's people have fears like
genetically sort of predisposed fears to
like scary dogs,
animals.
I mean we know you don't have to have a
dog bite you to know the dogs fucking
terrifying.
Like what is that like when a dog is
growling?
Like kids are afraid of teeth,
they're afraid of big teeth and
monsters.
Like even children that grow up in
cities,
they're afraid of monsters.
And the idea behind that that I've
heard,
I think it was rupert sheldrake there,
was talking about this.
He was saying that it may very well be
that these memories of being preyed upon
by like cats like that.
These genetic memories that are from our
ancient,
ancient ancestors.
When we didn't have homes and we were
living in trees and we were.
Things were running after us trying to
eat us and these ideas are passed down
from animal to animal and eventually
human to human.
I don't think it's as far as I know,
there's no solid evidence that suggests
that things you experience as a,
as a,
as an adult or child,
the experiences themselves can be can be
passed on the other than the verbally to
them when they're listening to your
stories that I'm not aware of.
Any mechanism that's known that would
allow that to happen,
haven't they've proven that genetics,
epigenetics and the in some some memes
like even useless ones like racism can
be transmitted from parent to child.
Not that I'm aware of,
but I don't know.
Obviously not my field of study either.
just a.
I'm just fascinated by the idea that we
don't totally understand all of the.
All the ingredients of the mind and
that's certainly true.
That's certainly true,
but I'm not aware of.
I don't know.
I doubt it because I can't see a
mechanism.
Brown butter?
No.
Are we back up,
jamie?
What's going on?
Tri caster froze.
Oh,
what a piece of shit that we paid
$15,000
for.
How dare you try castor people?
Meanwhile,
we should probably be excited that
someone figured that fucking thing out.
You think it might have to do with the
box and it gets heated up.
I have no idea.
No.
Just shit out on us.
Yeah,
most likely,
right?
How dare they?
One of the things that was proposed that
I read recently was that black holes
aren't real.
Is that nonsense?
Is that like one person's controversial
idea?
Yeah.
Basically,
it's not necessarily nonsense just
because it's one person's idea,
but it's likely to be nonsense.
I haven't seen that particular theory,
so I don't know.
I mean the.
We have a lot of good evidence for the
existence of black holes.
Not least theY predicted there
prediction of einstein's theory of
general relativity and they're there.
They're on solid theoretical ground and
we've seen the signatures of them.
So for example,
the object at the center of the milky
way galaxy,
we know what the masses of that object,
because we've measured the orbits of
stars very close to it.
We know what the maximum size of the
object can be because it can be bigger
than the orbits of the styles that go
around it,
and so we measure its mass.
I think it's about 4 million times the
mass of the sun and the only way that
our current laws of physics allow such
an object to exist and be so small is
for it to be a black hole.
So there's good evidence that black
holes are around,
but you can always say,
well,
you know,
we've never been to one.
They're very hard to photograph because
they're black,
but you can,
but you can photograph the stuff that
falls into them.
You can see the signature of stuff
fallen into them,
which we do
and they've,
they've.
What was it like?
It was somewhere in the two thousands.
They figured out that at the center of
every galaxies of supermassive black
hole that is like one half of one
percent of the mass,
the galaxy or something along those
lines.
We
think so.
As I said,
I think off the top of my head,
I think it's about 4 million times the
mass of the sun,
so the larger galaxies would have a
larger black hole.
I'm not sure if it's that.
It's not well understood actually
because he's not well understood how
galaxies form in the first place and
what role the supermassive black holes
having the formation of the galaxies,
so that's a real active area of
research.
Actually a good question.
The thing that I was reading was there
were debating the possibility that
inside each one of these supermassive
black holes,
so like there being hundreds of billions
of galaxies,
each one of them with a black hole in
the center of it,
a supermassive black hole in through
that black hole is a whole nother
universe with hundreds of billions of
galaxies.
Each with black holes go through that
whole hundred billion more galaxies.
hundred dollars,
billion more that
each galaxy itself literally as a portal
to a completely different universe.
We,
I mean we don't have a problem with
black holes,
is that their prediction of einstein's
theory?
One of the earliest predictions,
there's a thing called the swatch child
metric,
which describes black holes.
It was done I think in 1915 or 16 years,
right as soon as relativity was
published is when they're showing that
these things could exist,
um,
but uh,
we don't.
The theory itself Breaks down and then
the theory of black holes,
the general relativity,
which is the theory that explained
einstein's theory rejects so predicts
their existence,
but it doesn't.
The characteristics of black holes,
the physics inside black holes is not
understood.
We don't know.
Our theories don't work.
We need what's called a quantum theory
of gravity to make progress there.
So that's the unification of quantum
theory and relativity and general
relativity,
which is what string theory is an
attempt to do,
but we don't know whether that's the
right theory.
So,
so,
so we will see this is the edge of
knowledge.
So we don't know.
We don't know what we don't know how to
describe black holes.
Probably we have a theory that's capable
of describing.
We can describe the edge of this thing
about an event horizon and all that
stuff that works.
That's not a problem in einstein's
theory,
so the idea that if you have a
sufficiently den subject,
then there's a region around it.
I'm out of which light contest scape
because space and time are to curb for
light to get out.
That's,
that's fine.
The theory describes that properly,
but when you go,
when you start asking questions about
what happens at the center of a black
hole,
a singularity,
that very idea,
it's called a singularity tells you
their infinities in the theory.
The theory is doing things is infinitely
dentist.
It's infinitely small.
It's,
well,
no,
it won't be it.
We don't have infinities in general in
nature other than perhaps the size of
the university as you say.
It's so,
so,
um,
so there's something going on there,
but we don't have the physical theory.
We don't have the tools to describe it.
It's an active area of research.
So I don't know.
He's a good answer in science.
Right?
And so speculations fun,
but,
but ultimately,
you know,
we're talking about,
we're talking about a regime of nature,
uh,
which,
which are current theories and not
capable of describing with any
authority.
And that's,
that's the inside of a black hole.
We were talking about this before the
podcast,
the difference between the way you
present your shows and the bbc and the
way you're sort of forced to present
your shows on the science channel.
And this was one of the very issues as a
little bit,
I mean that's dealing with unknowns,
dealing with what you're describing,
things like black holes or like the
event horizon of a black hole that there
are points in time where you have to say
we don't know yet.
Yeah.
That we were talking earlier and I said
because at the moment we're a cyber
series in the uk called human universe,
which has been on in the uk,
um,
five episodes one hour long.
So we also make them with science
channel and besides channels one hour,
it's 43 minutes because they have
adverts,
right?
Commercials.
So fine,
that's the way.
So we've got to take 17 minutes out.
But also we have some interaction about,
well how do we nuance things for the.
Because you'll do things for a british
market that will be different in
american market.
And one of my favorites recently was
that one of the programs is about this
multiverse that we just talked about
earlier.
The fact that may be an infinite number
of universes.
The universe may have been around
forever.
There may be no beginning to the
universe,
all speculative,
right?
Then they have it.
So what does that mean?
It means that our existence is
inevitable.
We have to exist in an infinite universe
and we are because we have to be.
So there's no purpose to our existence.
There is no universal meaning to our
existence.
We are,
because we have to be an in the,
in the british virgin,
I say.
So to the camera.
How does that make you feel?
And the wonderful thing is nobody knows
this is new.
Physics is right at the edge.
It's speculative,
but we're beginning to address it with
the data and the theories.
So we need theologians and philosophers
and artists and novelists.
We need to discuss these things.
What does it mean for us?
If we're at our existence is inevitable
and we're not special,
but yet we may still be valuable.
It doesn't mean I don't know.
So the last thing I say in a british
version is so,
so what do you think say to the
audience,
and I think it's beautiful and it's
filmed over tokyo over tokyo skylight I
think is beautiful.
But I did get a note from the science
channel saying,
well the thing is that this is not the
style on the.
So we,
we tend to try and leave the viewer with
some concrete things.
So.
So can you tell them what it means for
the song and what the meaning of life,
the meaning,
the great existential question of what
does it mean to exist?
you want me to answer that?
Yes,
that'd be better for,
for our audience.
It's like,
well I really,
I'm a bit.
So I said,
you know,
what?
Can you tell me what to say?
Perhaps I'd love it if.
Look if science channel,
if you know the meaning of life,
then we tell me and I'll gladly say on
the blog,
I don't know.
So it was kind of interesting.
There's that difference in style,
but I loved it that they said,
can we do.
We really do want you to broadcast the
meaning of life undiscovered.
Nine o'clock,
because I can see how it'd be great
sell,
you know,
undiscovered tonight after sharks,
whatever they put on extra shot,
we were going to do the meaning of life
with professor Brian Cox.
Brian cox will tell you what it means to
exist for your existence,
to be inevitable in a possibly infinite
cosmos.
Find out at nine I either.
So it would be good.
It wouldn't be completely subjective.
What life means to you doesn't you know
jamie as a differences that need.
This is what we do do.
I do do in the series I.
This is what it's about.
It's a love letter to the human race,
human universe.
It's a.
You see that?
Certainly if you buy the one hour
version,
I don't know how it's gonna pan out in
43,
but if you,
if you get the one which you can buy
from good retailers on the internet,
it turns Out you need a.
It's not an itunes at the moment,
but you need it.
You need a 10 ati blu ray player.
I will say you do that,
not all us dvd players play 10,
eight year.
I content your plates and aup content,
technical stuff.
One of them is called interlaced and one
of them is called progressive scan.
There's virtually no difference except
that in europe we tend to.
So some of your blue ray players in
America will play it and some of them
won't.
It turns out I just found out they,
it's the one that the under blue ray,
you can buy it.
But um,
and I encourage you to because it's
wonderful.
But um,
but,
uh,
but so,
so there's something so,
but it'll be unsigned channel anyway in
a few months,
but it will cut down a bit.
But the,
but the central message is this,
that it we talked about earlier,
the,
it leads you,
I think to value the human race.
So there's like we filmed in Ethiopia,
which I love.
I always love filling in Ethiopia
because we were in the rift valley
filming this story about the emergence
of humans from the rift valley.
And then we filmed in some I call the
danica depression,
which is one of the,
other than death valley,
you advise with death valley often for
the hottest place on earth,
but it's far more barren and death
valley.
So if in northern Ethiopia on the
eritrean border there are volcanoes and
it's bleak and,
but there's a tribe of people call the
fr that lived there and they fascinating
and I stayed with them a few years ago
and they don't have a concept for
example,
of possessions because they don't have
anything.
They just live on these volcanoes,
in this wasteland.
So.
So they say if you put something down
like a something,
then they will legitimately pick it up
and they'll.
And they'll say,
well I'm going to use it for a while.
So when your film crew you kind of,
there's no cultural idea.
They're not stealing,
they're not taking stuff.
They don't have that idea because they
don't have anything.
So they leave the camera,
they might get your camera.
And we had some guards with those from
the for tribe,
but it's a bit dangerous there.
And he had an ak 47,
this guy and he sat there with his ak 47
and then we woke up one day and we had a
mountaineer with us.
So he got one of his mountaineering
ropes attached to his ak 47 and he sat
there now with this rope.
So the guy said to me,
she should I ask for it back because I
know number one,
it's attached to an ak 47,
which gives him the advantage.
We didn't believe we get into an
argument.
And number two,
it's fascinating.
I have no idea of possession.
But the reason I started saying that was
because we were filming.
We talk about meaning in life and we
said to this man who was called
a,
you didn't allie a guy at if our tribe,
small men,
probably four foot tall old.
And we said,
we're talking to you about this through
a translator.
And he said to us on camera,
he said,
you said your,
your,
your eyes have your age,
but your ears have your father's age,
your,
your is here the past and your eyes.
See the president.
And this is the way you should live,
and I just thought what a beautiful
thing that came out of this man,
and so we put that in the series just in
subtitled it and left it there because
it's full of little.
Just people celebrating those people is
something you'd never see.
You don't think there are people who
live on volcanoes in northern Ethiopia
that say wonderful things about your
ears.
I've been your father's age and your
your eye in the past being used through
your ears to manipulate an informed the
way you behave in the present.
Beautiful deep thoughts.
So we tried to fill the series with
those things as well.
So it's a mixture of cosmology and the
celebration of the wonder of human
existence.
The diversity of human thought.
It was beautiful stuff in there.
A love letter to the human race and why
not?
Because we deserve it.
What we're so adaptabLe.
The idea that people can live like that
with no possessions the same time where
people will live in a world that the r
one,
one of our biggest issues is that people
live to accumulate possessions.
And the idea of materialism is it's,
it's like it very much like you were
talking about the 17 year old boy that
only pays attention to video games that
becoming obsessed with anything,
whether it's becoming obsessed with
objects,
becoming obsessed with ideas.
Hey,
we're human beings,
we,
we are so flexible for so flexible in
how we can exist as a culture or as a
community that our ideas are so rigid
that people have to be this way.
And you know,
you can't run around on the Internet
saying that there's no meaning to life
when jesus,
his name is being broadcast right now on
christian ministries all throughout the
world.
They understand what the meaning of Life
is all about.
Brian cox,
you are the one who is ignorant to the
ways of the lord.
And I do think that the,
what I found is that travel.
Why would I,
because I filmed in,
I just fill it in.
I'm actually freeing for the monkey cage
free monkey age because because we're
doing the show is in their life.
You have to have a different kind of us
visa.
Right?
So,
so and,
and the visa you have to put,
where were you been in the last five
years?
How many countries have you visited
within the last five years and it at 38
I'd been to,
to fill in these things.
30 eight countries.
I thought,
wow.
I didn't know that.
That's a lot.
You know.
And what's interesting,
what I found it really honestly is that
when you go to Ethiopia or India or
Japan out into the wilds and these
places,
people tend to be relatively.
Well,
everyone I've met is first of all but
interested in stuff.
So through the translator with the
tribe,
we talk about the styles and I say as
I've got stars and they're interested so
that they don't,
they've never been to school.
They
have their own education,
they're up,
they're learning about how to live in a
volcanic wasteland,
but yet they're interested and the
things they're interested in common I
find.
And I genuinely am anyone that I found
uncomfortable,
I was uncomfortable with.
I haven't met any of the maniacs that we
consider,
we think of as in the world,
you know,
we think well it's okay here,
in,
in north America or in europe or
something,
we're okay,
but there's all these wild people out
there,
you know,
something I know.
I just haven't seen any evidence of
that.
And so that's part of human universe.
It's just trying to put these
impressions.
Yeah,
they believe different stuff.
So you might think,
you know,
like you said,
there's the people who say,
well jesus is the way,
but then you'll go to India and you'll
find that there are people who are
hindus who strange beliefs towards,
you know,
ganesh,
the blue elephant garden v,
they're part of that fabric of
understanding the universe.
And I find it wonderful actually.
It tells you something,
the,
there are some things that are cultural
and some things that are not religions,
cultural.
You go different places,
you have different religions.
That's not to say,
although I don't have any interest,
any interest in religion,
I always said people ask me quite a lot,
you know?
Do you really been gardens?
I know,
no,
but I don't really even think about it
until I get asked.
I would've never just stumbled across
that concept to myself.
I,
yeah.
I get asked a lot now because I do
science on television.
I know he said the same thing,
which is I don't really.
I'm not really interested.
I don't think about it.
It's all.
Is that upset anybody?
Well,
kind of because I don't want to be
dismissed.
I'm not trying to be missy and they just
talk about your own personal interests.
Does that,
does that upset you?
You're,
you're.
What I'm saying is I'm just reaffirming
what you're saying.
You're just talking about your own
personal interests,
like why do,
why does your personal lack of an
interest in something upset people,
but it seems to right?
Well,
it can do because I think it says
central part of the framework they use
to explain the world and meeting and all
these questions that we're discussing.
We should.
Difficult questions and I think don't
have answers,
right?
I don't eat it.
It's a complicated question.
What does it mean to be alive?
And as we said,
it obviously means something personally,
but I don't.
These are complicated question,
but I think what's interesting is you go
around the world and you see that these
questions are common and people think
about them in wherever they are,
wherever their level of education,
they have some framework for
understanding that,
but there are also commonalities are
large.
The,
the curiosity about the stars is
something that you see everywhere you
see the curiosity about the origins of
the universe and there are stories which
are different all over the world.
All in my view and in the human universe
view with an equally valid,
right?
They're,
they're,
they're all worth it.
I don't consider it from them.
I think they're interesting.
They're interesting responses to nature.
I think it's these people that live
around this volcano.
How do they survive?
What are they eating?
Like they have goats.
Um,
the,
they managed to feed on the Limited tiny
amounts of limited vegetation that's
there,
very little water.
So they're very careful with the water,
um,
but they,
they've developed this way of living
there.
They're remarkable,
tough,
really tough bunch of people.
How many people live up there?
I don't know actually how big the font
is,
but he's one of the Ethiopia is very
tribal and it goes into Eritrea as well.
So it's in this area,
at the top of the rift valley.
It's called the triple afar junction,
which is a tectonics plate tectonics.
It's where all the volt vulcanism at the
top of the rift is.
So it's the generator of the rift
valley,
you'd be like,
is beautiful actually.
Is it an idea?
Because this is the cradle of humanity.
So,
so,
so you've got this is,
I find it a magical place actually.
Ethiopia for that reason.
And it said I recommend it actually had
addie sandberg is a beautiful city.
He said high altitude city.
Um,
so Ethiopia tend to think of,
especially if you're a kid of my
generation,
you think in live aid and the big famine
in Ethiopia,
you think it is dusty place and it is in
some areas,
but actually the,
the capital,
it's a very green countries is high
altitude,
quite pleasant city as some african
cities when they're very hot and they
did.
It can be very unusual for people like
us from places are not dusty and hot and
but at is not like that actually.
And I was and I,
I find this an idea when I go there,
I like the idea that because you,
you kind of almost know that we came
from there.
Somehow you come armed with this
knowledge.
This is,
that we were all related to someone who
lived here in,
in and around adis abba in the rift
200,000
years ago were all related to someone
who lived there.
And we wandered out from there.
I find that a powerful thought actually,
and he dismisses,
you know,
the great deal of talk of differences
amongst us.
but actually you go to Ethiopia,
you,
you realize very soon that we're not far
back because you said you trace your
generators,
parents,
father,
grandfather back,
right back.
You don't go far back before you get to
an ethiopian.
She's quite wonderful.
I think so.
It's so pretty
active enhancing to to see people in
this day and age.
I was watching a documentary on people
that live in the amazon that are barely
contacted by the western world.
They sort of,
they made have like american underwear
or something that someone gives them.
But other than that,
like you know,
these people have been living
essentially very similar to the way
they've been living thousands of years
ago and they're getting by.
They're fine and it just,
it makes you realize like how,
how this world that we live in right now
that we think everybody has to have an
email address,
everybody has to at least have some form
of public transportation.
No,
they don't.
You don't.
You don't have to have anything.
These people all walk around,
they walk around in the jungle and they
live and they've been living like.
And They know what to eat,
you know what not to eat and they know
what to avoid and they have babies and
their culture continues and they don't
even write things down and they'd been
living like that for a long time.
And they're people just like you and
just like me.
Yeah.
With the same.
I find the same level of curiosity and
interest is,
it's kind of sometime more so.
Well.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it's very interested in that
perspective.
The people that you contacted in
Ethiopia,
how many,
how many are in their group,
the ones that you were in contact with
that?
Um,
maybe I'd be guessing 100 or so in this
kind of.
Do they have a writteN history?
No,
no.
Oral history.
Yeah.
So these are stories passed down from
generation,
so they're great storytellers.
Wow.
The results in these isolated tribes.
I mean obviouslY Ethiopia is a
fascinating country because it's one of
the few countries in africa that in an
ancient country,
I mean they,
they,
they're,
they're in biblical times.
You know,
they've got these myths about when you
get to our this,
they say we've got the uh,
the ark of the covenant running
cathedral in adis.
Then you say,
can I see it?
And they go,
no,
but iT's there.
But I like the mythology.
The mythology is that the queen of sheba
was up there and stole it,
I think,
and came back and brought it back
selling author of king solomon and
solomon wouldn't.
So yeah,
so you've got this.
It's all intertwined.
It's the fact that they're,
they're written history.
The central ethiopian written history
is,
is in the biblical,
in its,
in its spanish ancient Egypt.
They were part of that thing that Egypt
and,
and in Ethiopia and then into jerusalem,
those areas palestine and then out to
you that,
that,
that thousand year old 2000 year old
history is part of that country.
Very centrally part of it.
Whereas usually in africa,
you know,
you get countries that were divided up
and they came after the second world war
and he post-imperial things.
But Ethiopia is a real,
a more grounded place in history.
So it's a fascinating place.
What is the area that's supposed to
contain the ark of the covenant that
cathedral allegedly,
um,
in,
in this,
as I say,
I wasn't allowed to see it,
so I'm very tied that exist,
but only people were supposed to be like
looking at it.
How many,
how nobody argues with this myth.
So is it like al capone's vault where
like it took joe geraldo rivera to break
down the wall before we realized there
was nothing in it.
I mean,
is there like a room that no one goes
into?
I think other than the priests and
things really,
I think that's because someone wants to
build the cathedral in and obviously the
queen of shiva stolen in the first
place.
So it's not there anymore.
It is let from jerusalem.
Oh,
and brought it to Ethiopia.
Yes.
Right.
And took it down to Ethiopia.
Managing if it is something that,
some technological object from a
forgotten time,
you under it and go,
oh yeah,
you know,
what,
stop do you remember?
Um,
there was,
there was some work that was done on
ancient batteries where they've,
uh,
they believe that some,
some of the artifacts they found like
egyptian pyramids perhaps might have
functioned in
a very similar way to a modern battery.
I saw that.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean it's possible I suppose.
And we,
again,
we talked about timescales.
It's three and a half thousand for my
fans and years.
You know,
the,
the earliest pyramids.
I think so.
Um,
yeah,
we,
we don't know.
We know quite a lot about the,
the egyptians.
Again,
it's about human universe,
especially my monkey cage.
And I'll talk about giving university as
well because we,
we found um,
my wife actually started learning.
Egyptians were just interested in
hieroglyphics.
She just got some classes and the
literature from ancient Egypt is
fascinating.
You're talking about three year,
2000 bc is things that have been written
down and the earliest I locked in,
I want it in the book of human universe,
which you can get in the us,
I should say.
I went into,
look,
I want dailies literature.
What is it?
And it's basically the,
one of the earliest things I could find
was basically monty python's parrot
sketch because it's,
this is a complaint.
And he said,
I wish to register a complaint.
It's a piece of papaya,
iris.
And it's a complaint about,
um,
I think it was the,
the,
the coffin.
It was a,
as a coffee manufacturer who had
supplied this coffee and there was the
wrong size and it was kind of a bit of a
ripoff.
And this person said,
I'm complaining about this,
I want to send it back.
This is terrible.
I want my money back.
And they'd say,
well,
you can have two coffIns instead.
And he,
I don't want a voucher.
I want my money.
And so you see this was wonderful,
is it's a modern voice that echoes down
the ages from ancient Egypt that they,
most of them are either admin.
Things about my garden was nicked a bit
of my garden.
You moved the fence in the night or
something like that.
All complaining about some piece of
commerce like this is,
I've been ripped off by the shopkeeper
and it's terrible and it's wonderful.
But then they're also poems,
fantastic poems,
there's one about a woman talking to her
husband and under the awareness,
the husband talking to him,
and so you go through and he's saying,
why did you leave me?
Why didn't you love me?
It's quite touch in a meeting.
And then you realize towards the end
that this,
this,
um,
woman died,
she's dead,
but he's still talking to it like that
because the egyptians thought that,
you know,
she'd moved on,
conscious,
a conscious decision to go into the
afterlife.
And so there's this kind of bitterness
being expressed and this really moving
piece of poetry and then you realize
that it's 4,000
years old us,
you know,
it's wonderful actually.
So you found,
we haven't changed at the point that you
find from this old literature,
what will the,
one of the oldest pieces of human
language was the cuneiform right from
somewhere?
I read this one thing that was,
there was a passage they were talking
about that was about divorce.
Yeah,
iT was about marriage and divorce.
There was something along like,
um,
uh,
I forget what it was like a sort of a
very short poem about divorce,
about marriage
and uh,
you know,
for your relief or for your pleasure.
Divorce was very bizarre,
like the concept of two people uniting
by ritual existed six,
whatever,
five,
6,000
years ago and they wrote about it in
these little scratches,
you know,
the,
the cuneiform which looks like ancient
nails with a flat top and a that points
down and then a certain pattern they've
been able to figure out that it means
some form,
some language that you can kind of
attempt to translate to our modern
languages in a weird,
clunky,
you know,
have you ever read like Russia,
like the russian translations from
russian to english.
It's so bizarre because their language
is so alien to us.
It's so different that the way they use
pronouns and the subtext and all the
different aspects that we sort of take
for granted about language don't
translate correctly.
Yeah.
And you think you mentioned that
hieroglyphics.
Yeah.
Could I like the fact that the voice is
so familiar.
We haven't changed the library of
alexandria man,
the burning of the library of
alexandria,
if we had never taken place and we could
somehow or another go back and read all
the shit that they knew about
construction methods and how they built
those things and what was the purpose
behind them and what was the
significance of the astronaut
astrological alignment.
Like what,
what were they doing,
why were they,
what they were doing was so insane in
comparison to the greater some of
humanity.
Like if you look at humans,
2,500
bc and then you look at Egypt,
you like jesus christ.
What the fuck happened here?
How did you guys figure this shit out
that no one else anywhere near w w was
anywhere close to this level of
sophistication.
Modern construction.
The second thing you can take from this,
because if you look at ancient Egypt,
so of course if you go to some of the
temples down there on denial and look,
so in particular,
it's just astonishing achievement.
I you that.
You look at Greece,
you look at the greek literature,
and then you look at the library of
alexandria,
which the knowledge was lost because the
barbarians came and burn the thing down
and you realize that civilizations rise
and fall and knowledge can be lost,
and the the,
the,
the romans,
I suspect though they were eternal as a
civilization,
they were continuing to progress the
greeks before.
they haven't felt that.
The egyptians thought that they didn't.
we think that now,
and it's interesting to reflect,
I think on the fact that you don't have
to make progress.
The progress is in your own hands so you
can choose to make progress.
They didn't choose to make progress for
various reasons.
They stopped making progress and they
vanished and knowledge vantage with a
lot of the time and I think it's a
lesson for us.
We could do that.
You know,
we,
we just maybe we've got into this
position now with our technology were
just,
it just won't go like that,
but only we can take it for granted.
Which I think goes back to right back to
the start of the conversation
about how do we,
how do we say to people,
you know,
the,
this is a remarkable thing that we've
done,
but it don't take it for granted.
He's not just going to tick along while
you guys sit there and watch sports all
the time,
right?
That's not the way that you make
progress.
Somebody got to do something and we've
all got to support the people.
Even if you don't want to do it,
then support the people that want to do
it.
So you look at the,
you know,
I was,
I was filming with them on friday for a
thing I'm doing in britain with a rusty
spigot who's an apollo nine c test flu,
the lunar module and apollo nine in
1968.
First test flight of it in earth orbit
before they went to the moon in july of
that year.
And um,
and uh,
so he,
we landed on the moon actually in India.
We were in a simulator is terrific and
he showed me how to do it and it's
fantastic.
But you look at nasa,
the investment in nasa at that time,
it was never more than four percent of
the federal expenditure and actually it
was often less than that,
so it wasn't particularly expensive on
average,
maybe about three percent of federal
expenditure,
but it laid the foundation I could argue
for american technological dominance in
the last quarter of the 20th century
because for example,
the,
the average age of the engineers in the
nasa mission control when apollo 11
landed on the moon was below 30,
below 30 years old.
Those engineers.
So what happened to them after the
apollo program,
they went out to work for boeing and you
know,
microsoft bell labs,
bell labs or lockheed martin or whoever
it is,
all these people.
So you get this explosion in,
in technological achievement,
in economic growth in America is a
terrific place to be a because in,
in many ways because of the growth that
happened in those 30 or 40 years since
apollo and,
and,
but that was because of a conscious
investment led by,
you know,
kennedy's great speech and also inspired
by the cold war,
et cetera.
There's many reasons why I did it,
but ultimately that investment paid vast
dividends.
You look at nasa today and the
investment is way down,
so the ambition that the America had to
go to the moon because it's there and to
beat the russians yet,
but to do it and then that ambition
seems to be missing to me and I looked,
I,
I looked to this country actually
because I think it is the country know
the country could have done that.
They get no,
the country could.
Gun moon will go.
I think before this decade is out,
we'll go and they hadn't flown anyone in
space.
When kennedy made that speech,
you hadn't flown anyone in space and you
say,
within 10 years I'm going to walk on the
moon.
That's an american thing to do.
I think this is part of what's great
about this country and I regret the fact
that that doesn't seem to be there at
the moment,
and going back to why I started saying
that the,
the,
the idea that progress is progress is
comes to the bold,
right?
I would say so the idea that it will
just come,
they will just make progress and is not
necessarily right.
In fact,
history tells us it's wrong,
so you've got to have,
I believe bold visions and visionary
leaders and leaders are just say,
well,
this is not a great deflection of
resources.
It was,
as I say,
it was always less than three,
four percent of federal expenditure,
but it's a great reflection of national
will and it's a great generator of fsc,
of engineers and scientists who are
inspired by those things and trained in
that process.
That guy into the economy make the
economy better.
There's a study that suggested it was a
14 to one return on every dollar
invested in apollo by 1980 and people
can argue about the um,
the 10 to was 14 to one.
Was it 22?
One is the return to the private sector
or return to the government that gdp
into,
in just into wealth generated.
So,
so each one made tang each one of those
dollars generating at least 10 and maybe
20 in a decade.
And it's obvious how it did it.
Because look at those young engineers
and look at the technologies that were
developed for a follow.
Someone said to me at nasa ames up in
san francisco,
virtually virtually every technology and
commercial aviation today got invented
there in at nasa ames.
Actually most of it,
so,
so you can point to one place and go,
that's where everything I take for
granted when I get in an aircraft came
from that almost directly.
Do you think it's because of the,
the,
the ending of the cold war or the lack
of competition with Russia?
There's.
We were on top,
so we just got soft.
There was no need to keep pushing and
pressing.
There wasn't an adversary.
There wasn't this technological
adversary that's out there that gives
people the motivation to continue to
invest.
Forty percent of the gross domestic
product or whatever,
you know,
whatever the.
The amount of money we need.
I don't know.
It seems.
I have to look at britain,
so I talk about my country,
which did the big thing around the world
and then declined.
It doesn't run the world anymore.
Handed it over to you guys.
You guys had a little island.
He ran it out of an island.
It's pretty dope.
Yeah.
We have a big ass continent.
We set off in the wrong place.
Did it out of Rhode Island.
It's kind of smaller than California.
Yeah,
it was pretty crazy for awhile.
not bad,
but it seems to me that what we lack is
the.
These things are not expensive.
In fact,
they're vital.
They generate money,
so it seems to me it's leadership.
It's visionary leadership by
inspiration.
Yeah,
and it doesn't take it well.
I was gonna say it doesn't take much
clear.
It took a kennedy,
I think.
I mean that speech.
He's a remarkable speech.
Rallies a nation beyond something,
but it's not a particularly large
diversion of resources.
That's the point and certainly given the
what you get back,
it seems to me the investment in r and d
in science and technology and education,
these are the things that formed the
foundation of our future.
Absolutely.
And everybody agrees with that and I get
very involved.
I get involved in politics in britain,
but not party politics,
but this lobbying for this,
spend money on the young,
spend money on education system,
spend money on inspiration,
make sure that there's a generation of
these great engineers and scientists
that America is currently well leading
in.
Absolutely.
um,
and make sure that they're still there
and make sure.
And how do you get them?
How do you inspire them?
I don't want kids to want to be a
singer's actually,
particularly annex x factor.
I don't want them to be famed.
When there was a survey done recently I
think where they said to the lower
school kids what you want to be when you
grow up and,
and,
and a lot of them said,
famous,
famous.
What do you mean famous?
You want to walk on the moon?
Don't you want to.
Do you want to invent the world's
fastest computer?
Don't do you want it?
What do you mean famous?
You've got to be famous for something
not famous because you want a talent
show.
We go back to the pole.
Can kardashians?
I'd never seen the cardassians by the
way.
I don't know who the hell they are and
thank god I don't because I don't know.
We don't,
I don't think we have them in britain
that maybe we do,
but they get over there.
Do they get over that?
We'd done it,
I'm sure,
but I want to pick on that lot.
I mean they're doing what they do.
Right.
But the point is you don't want to be
one of those without being disrespect.
Maybe they,
they're having a good time,
find insult people and then at the same
time people kind make their make their
way,
you know,
and do well and they're not criminals.
They're not evil people.
They're not.
Those is what do you want to aspire to
be as,
as a kid?
What do you want to aspire to be?
And it's true.
They're in their sixties.
They wanted it to be neil armstrong,
uh,
or one of the engineers in mission
control.
And that's a government government has.
I know it's kind of unfashionable in
some circles,
but government sets the,
sets the direction in the,
it has to.
It's,
you know,
companies can do it as well.
So you have the big companies like apple
and google and so people do aspire to
work with those companies,
but I think the grand direction of
civilization is set by set by
governments and visionaries and and,
and it's not expensive,
but it's terrifically expensive not to
do it.
For governmenTs to the idea of
government is really been hijacked in
this country and come apart.
Money being catalytic,
I don't know.
You know,
it depends what you mean by government
and big government,
small government,
special interest groups and the
law.
Like it's just too much money involved.
The complaints being there's legal,
like absolutely legal corruption in this
country.
Like we're giant corporations are
allowed to invest enormous sums of money
into candidates that will,
once they get into office,
you do the bidding of these corporations
manipulate laws,
move things around,
make things easier for these
corporations to manipulate our society.
That's a realIty and that's very
unfortunate.
But I think that's a reality that's also
being a roading or eroding rather by
technology.
I think people understanding the
mechanisms involved in government is
making them want to change those
mechanisms.
People pushing for ideas lIke being able
to vote online.
This is like people were really
frustrated by this oil.
How come I can bank online?
how come you can deal with the entire
world's economy through computers and
the internet,
but you can't vote?
How come is it because you don't want it
to be that easy for people to give their
opinion,
people to vote because
the world of the internet and the world
of of actual voting there too,
there's a big gap between them.
There's a big gap that would instantly
shift right over if you were allowed to
vote online and these people this,
oh,
there's problems with that.
Oh,
corruption,
oh this.
Or you're the one who's always worried
about hacking.
Well,
guess what?
That's going to be the case.
No matter what you do,
there's goIng to.
There's all sorts of problems with
voting the conventional way.
I mean America,
we've had giant scandals and diebold
voting machines that contained the third
party access,
the ability to manipulate the data.
It's all been proven.
There was a documentary called hacking
democracy that showed how ludicrous it
is to think that our system that's in
place right now is is infallible,
not,
not only that,
it's massively flawed.
The technology that exists because of
the internet,
because of the ability to exchange
information instantaneously with each
other is unprecedented,
and I think that is going to shift the
idea of government that's going to shit.
It's going to scatter all these crazy
people that are running things right
now.
It's not going to be viable anymore.
just like kings aren't viable anymore.
You can't be henry the eighth in 2015
unless you're the guy in North Korea.
He's like the last one,
but most.
Most governments can't be run the way
they were run thousands of years ago.
There's too much access to information.
We know you're not a god.
We know you're just a person.
You know,
we,
we have this ability to exchange these
ideas so quickly that the word gets out
too fast.
You're listening to tim.
Ben is lee when he talks about the
worldwide web and eventually by the way
it said,
of course the web bits of it,
and then then he talks in those terms.
Actually he's quite idealistic and
honestly I am a freedom of information
free exchange of information and I think
you're right.
I mean it goes right back to the
beginning of the conversation,
doesn't it is a good thing or a bad
thing on the web.
Let's say a good thing or a bad thing
and you must be right in this sentence
that they,
as long as people you know you need to
set and we're having this conversation
at quite a high level.
if you know we're talking about great
movements and great shifts in
civilization and so I suppose you need
a.
You need the perspective first.
Don't you need the.
You need your appetite stimulating for
knowledge and information and to use not
to use the internet or the web to get to
as yourself,
you need to have some instinct that I'm
not going to just go find the little
sliver of information that interests me
and perhaps inflammation that's
nonsensical and is also the,
you know,
how you you can go and be a conspiracy
theorist and find plenty of information
to support your conspiracy.
He will see that tool kit so you can
always talks about this in the demon
haunted world.
Again,
by giving people a toolkit.
Bullshit detectors,
I think he called it,
you know,
the education science,
the scientific method that that's a
bullshit detector kit basically.
So if you can get that in there,
you can get that in.
Maybe this is the priority really in
schools to say,
well,
I want you to know how to think,
how to look information,
assess where the information came from,
understanding if it's likely to be
tainted or biased or good or bad,
or how do I assess this vast quantity
information out there?
How do I not get it?
Whereas myself,
how do I decide that I'm only going to
read,
I'm only going to is the external forums
that say that we didn't land on the moon
and there was a big conspiracy and
everyone covered it up.
How?
How can I broaden my reach to say,
is that really true?
Shall I check some other stuff like the
telescopes?
That way you can look at the spacecraft
on the moon,
you know that kind of bits of evidence.
So I think that's very important.
Isn't it ironic that in this day and age
we accumulate more data.
I think there was some statistic about
in every two days we accumulate more
data,
more like numbers and a lot of it's
probably instagram pictures and twitter
and shit that's useless,
but that more hard data gets accumulated
or processed or or or produced by humans
today.
Then the entire time of human history up
to that point,
which is fucking staggering.
Yeah,
but it also,
most of it takes place on computers.
The most of it is ones and zeros.
Most of it takes place in a language
that you.
And I can't even read if it was written
on a piece of paper,
no one.
And it's a big subject.
And how do you use data and how do we
use it?
There's.
There's an example that the program I do
in the uk called stargazing live.
She'll live astronomy show on the bbc
and lots of people watch it.
It's kind of people like it.
One of the things that we do a citizen
science projects,
so for example last year that we use the
european space agency's database of
photographs of the surface of mars.
Nobody's ever looked at them,
right?
There's too many of them.
So we've got too many pitches of miles,
no one know human eyes have ever looked
at these pictures.
So we ran a project where we wanted to
answer a question about some features
that we're seeing moving across the
surface of mars,
weather features that we thought may be
seasonal.
So maybe in the martian winter they
moved down to the equator.
Let me back up again in the summer.
Didn't know.
Then we proved that they were indeed
seasonal by getting millions of people
who watched the program to go look at
the pictures for the first time so you
can go online now and look at pictures
of mars.
Let's saY that nobody's ever seen it
because it's too much data,
even the of the planet,
so imagine the amount of data generated
on this planet that no one's ever done,
that no one's ever looked at this date.
They'll be data about what a increases
the likelihood of certain cancers.
For example,
there'll be the lifestyle that does that
doesn't engender that alone will be
there in the data,
but no one's quite got their head around
now to go and mine that data and try to
use it.
It just.
Using the data is extremely difficult
and challenging,
but you're right,
it's there.
No one ever looks at it will not only
that,
the idea of somehow or another
preserving this,
if there was some event super volcano
eruption,
like they're constantly worried about
yellowstone and there's one in
Indonesia,
I believe it is,
that they believe is connected to a mass
extinction event that killed off a giant
swath of the population.
Oh,
they're nasty.
They're the super volcanoes.
Terrifying one of those to go and if one
of those hits and somehow or another,
the power goes out all around the world
and the only people that survive are
those folks that live by the volcano.
Fuck man.
We're starting from scratch.
Like I mean relatively in terms of the
universe.
That's nothing.
So you big baby.
You got to wait another 10,000
years civilization to reemerge and
someone to reinvent the internet,
you know,
and the ark of the covenant and still
locked up in Ethiopia because they
already did this and they already
figured out how to make nuclear bomb or
something like that.
When those the fuck it is.
But the,
the,
the.
For our immediate life,
it's so critical to not just acquire
this information,
but to nurture it and to spread it.
I mean,
that's your whole idea,
right?
You're,
you're just talking about expanding
science and education and getting people
excited and involved,
but that doesn't mean jack shit.
If The fucking earth spits out a giant
ball of lava that engulfs half of north
America and that kills 90 percent of the
planet,
like we're starting from scratch and
there's not.
None of this is going to be any good.
No computers,
no hard drives,
no flash drives,
no fucking database.
It's all bullshit.
The cloud go fuck your cloud.
It's not really in the cloud.
I've got news for you.
It's down on earth and oh,
it's in the cloud.
No,
it's not.
There's no cloud.
Okay.
It doesn't exist.
You go up and look around for your
fucking data.
It's not there in someone's goddamn
building.
Okay?
It's a fucking building.
Stop saying it's in the cloud because
it's not a dirty,
stinky,
live.
That's reality.
Unless you're launching that fucking
shit up,
it would have taken all the hard drives
of all the world and launching it into
space and you know,
on a 10,000
year loop.
So it comes back around and lands to,
you know,
you do it.
90 nine point nine percent of the speed
of light.
So the data you're getting back again,
it comes back.
Could you imagine if that's what happens
like one day just they do,
they pick a strategic location that they
believe will be a large population of
life and it really lands 10,000
years later and we go,
oh fuck,
look at this.
Look at all the shIt they knew and it's
all in dos or whatever.
Some something that we could read like
fairly easily.
They run it through some computers and
they realized like,
wow,
fucking people been around.
Do you remember my first,
my first operating system on a pc?
There's dust five.
Remember that I was postdoc.
The first computer that I ever had had
windows 95 and windows 95 was the big
deal.
My friend chris made computers with
windows three point two,
three point one when she ran on dust.
So.
So I,
yeah,
I had no windows when I first got my
first pc.
Wow.
Cool.
That's crazy.
And if you think about how recent you
kind of guy named matt on that.
Yeah,
right.
If someone sends you a picture,
it's way bigger than that.
Yeah.
Every fucking pictures.
100 million.
Right.
And if you think that that was 1995,
it was only 20 years ago and in 20 years
a blink of an eye,
you know,
a blink of an eye.
I think we should get back to dos you
think?
Yeah.
Why?
Because you want to know that it
competes.
It worked.
You got to,
you got to have these little also exec
that files that designed the memory of.
Isn't that like more work than you need,
isn't it?
It's a big deal in the sentence because
we,
we have a problem with getting kids to
write code because they'll think it's a
lot of work to write code,
right?
Yeah.
But like in the old days with the
computers,
you have friends that make video games
and one of the most shocking things was
the,
the sheer amount of hours that go into
coding video games.
You know,
the folks at id software,
they let me in behind the scenes and
epic games to cliff.
He be our friend cliff.
He was on the podcast before I would
watch those guys work.
They would do 16 hour days and they
would just be coding and drinking
fucking caffeine and just staring in
front of these monitors and just running
over thousands of lines of code.
And you're like,
oh,
that's how you make a fucking video
game.
It's kind of 100 million dollar.
Things are unbelievable.
They like movies.
Well,
they're bigger than movies.
The average huge gambling,
uh,
grand theft auto.
When those games get released,
they're there.
The amount of money that they generate
Is rival to like avatar.
Some huge spectacular hit.
Like not an average movie,
but it just gigantic,
monumental,
epic,
huge successful movie that's like an
average video game.
Grand theft auto and madden.
When those madden games come out,
the fucking world changes.
Like I mean people generally,
there's so much income that gets poured
into those video games and you realize
that it's a lot of just people just
coding because standing in front of
computers and just pounding on a
keyboard,
it's madness.
You know,
maybe that's the way that western
civilization falls.
The coders stopped,
people stopped fucking going to happen.
They're going to stop breeding.
That's just gonna happen.
Women.
Women will stop having sex with motors
and it's all going to fucking end all
their accumulated knowledge that we were
talking about before.
Like the coders making children that are
better coders.
Nope.
Just ends one day.
Maybe you can wrIte four tran.
Yeah.
One day we wake up and we realized that
no one's making video games anymore.
So we go to these places where they made
video games.
So like,
hello,
everybody's dead cobwebs everywhere.
They just died and no one fucked up the
apocalypse.
No.
Well,
imagine if computer coders ceased to
exist and all of us were forced to back
engineer computer code if today,
like for somehow or another,
I don't know how many people in this
world have a deep understanding of
computer operating systems or computer
code,
but I couldn't imagine it's more than
one percent and if we lost one percent
of the population just disappeared from
the earth.
And then the rest of us dopes.
We're left to observe our cell phone
crashing or fucking tri caster over
here.
That shit the bed on us mid broadcast.
I mean if that's a critical part of our,
our society of civilization itself and
it totally overlooked.
So you coders out there,
god bless,
keep breathing,
and breathing.
Breathing and breathing with the praise
odin for the coders.
It's amazing.
It's so amazing.
If you really think of how much our life
in our civilization revolves around
electronics and around computer code,
which you a monkey cage and essentially,
yes,
I mean it's stunning.
If you really stop and think about it,
every single thing that used to be
mechanical and a and an analog is now
computer like cars.
ThIs,
the main for car enthusiasts is one of
the main complaints is that you don't
feel what a car is doing anymore.
One of the thrIlls of driving an older
car like especially in old sports car,
they're not as fast.
They don't handle as well,
but you feel everything you feel the
road because it's a mechanical steering.
There's no assisting.
Like if you go to like a 1973 porsche
nine slash 11,
there's no.
There's no hydraulic assist in the
steering.
It's all mechanical.
you feel every pebble.
You literally feel the mechanism turning
the tire.
You feel the tires losing their grip.
It's all transmitted through your seat
and through your hands and people live
for this.
It's like exciting stuff,
but if you drive a modern porsche,
it's like there's a million operations
that are going on behind the scenes and
every second to avoid collisions and
slow your tires down and breaking on the
right side because you're turning left.
I was like,
all this shit that's going on that you
don't even know.
You don't even feel it.
There's a magnetic ride control system
that's adjusting.
There's like there's certain cars now,
like I believe mercedes benz has a
camera that looks at the road in front
of you and gauges whether or not the
suspension should be compliant or rigid.
It adjusts and you can go,
I think up to like 30 miles an hour.
You just take your hand off the wheel
and put it in cruise control and fucking
turns based on the lines on the road.
Do you think that said that the first
sentence being is going to be a nine
slash 1117?
I hope it's an american car.
I hope it's corvette or maybe perhaps a
truck.
Maybe an f150 takes out godless
heathens.
Just drives around,
eats assholes.
Um,
I,
I wonder,
you know,
I,
I think for sure if we can live you and
I'm 47,
how old are you?
40 seven.
So if we could live another,
if we get really lucky,
we live another 50 years based on modern
interpretation of science and medicine.
I'm actually 46 by the way,
hopefully 70 march just because now got
lexus open.
Get at least you added the right way.
You know if you like.
I'm 40 ish.
I have a friend who won't tell me his
age in edwards.
He won't tell me how old he is.
A motherfucker.
I think he's my age,
but he won't say it.
I should.
I should've said 47 because then we
could pay the real change.
Yeah,
very funny.
Wikipedia wikipedias long wrong about a
lot of shit.
I just filled it.
Still thinks brian counts my brother.
It's still thinks I'm five feet tall.
If you.
If,
if you consider this idea that we.
If we everything goes correct and we
live to be 95 years old.
Let's go.
Let's go there for sure.
there's going to be something.
You know there's gonna be some.
They've already got these little
japanese talking head ones that look
erie.
Very strange sort of artificial faces
that talk to you.
There's gonna come a point in time as
the exponential increase in technology,
whether it's 20,
30 years where they're going to make
fake fucking people.
Man,
let me,
let me pull it up.
Something else.
Nothing to do with me.
This friend of mine,
alex garland,
it just made a film called ex makena and
which is a great science fiction film,
which shouldn't be coming to the states.
It's just been released in the uk x
magazine.
Can I get it online somewhere legally?
Not illegally,
I suppose illegally.
Can I get it?
That's a problem.
You fucker the second legal so I can get
it.
You'll see the trailer,
you can get the trailer on youtube,
but it's been released in the states.
Can't remember when,
but it's,
it's great.
And it's about,
it's about an ai,
uh,
a female ai and it's uh,
it's about a guy kind of like one of
these elan musk type guy guys.
He lives out in the woods and he and
he's built one of these things and he
gets one of his employees to come and do
a turing test on it,
which is to see if he thinks that this
thing has sentience,
this ai.
But she's beautiful and it kind of goes
off from there.
But alex wrote the beach and he wrote 28
days later
say
really brilliant science fiction film,
but it,
it is slow.
Some of these issues that we've been
talking about about what it is to be
human,
are the ais bathers,
are they better than it was morally
physically strange?
What is it that.
Why is this girl so beautiful white
wine?
Did he make this beautiful woman?
It's just,
it's a great film.
So I recommend that to everyone who's
listening.
That sounds amazing.
when is it going to be released here?
It must be very soon because it's been.
It's just been out in the uk.
Did very well.
Is it going to be released in theaters
or is a digital release April 10th in
America.
So you'd.
wow,
that sounds.
That's a great concept.
I mean,
I,
I've said for a long time,
but I believe the first artificial
intelligence be sex slaves.
People are going to make artificial
sucks.
People.
People that are going to have sex with
like is it cheating to use a device?
Is it cheating to masturbate?
Some people say yes,
I was reading a forum article was people
arguing as guys arguing with his wife.
She's saying if he doesn't stop
masturbating,
she's going to divorce him specifically
to,
you know,
augie with his hand and say he ended the
insightful advice.
Seven faithfulness just beat his hand
up.
But um,
then,
you know,
it goes from masturbation to
masturbation using technology and the
internet to watch pornography to
masturbation using a device.
Like they have these,
uh,
you know,
what oculus rift is,
I'm sure.
Right.
That's good.
I should go with that.
The new version of it.
My friend duncan called me up.
I was at the improv and when,
you know,
when he called me,
I was about to go onstage.
It was like five minutes for I go on
stage and he had just got back from some
three d virtual reality conference and
he's just screaming at my phone.
It's a fucking game changer,
man.
This is the craziest shit.
I said that it was the,
the hd quaLity was stunning.
I did 70.
Let me have a look at the one that we,
there's an oculus and something else.
They use them for the past four,
which is not going.
It's not out yet.
We did it in 12 months.
I think.
Something like that.
It's amazing that they showed me this
demo and it's a real.
It's like it's done.
Very,
very good.
I think that is going to be a game
changer.
Well,
they decided to do first person
pornography with these things that
supposed to just be like there was a
real issue that people are going to have
with being addicted to this stuff
because I don't believe that our minds.
I think one of the.
One of the reasons why people have such
a deep,
like what we were talking about earlier,
that people get angry,
a dumb programming and people get angry
at,
you know,
dumb songs and dump television shows.
One of the reasons I think we have this
instinct to get upset at it is we.
I think we inherently understand that
we're not designed to process the media
that we've created.
We're designed to imitate the successful
behaviors or other tribal members.
We were designed to listen to people
like you talk and be inspired,
but you're right here.
I'm looking right at you.
It evolved,
right?
You're not,
you're saying,
well,
I don't mean it in that sense.
I mean in a sense of how we function
evolved.
I'm sorry,
I don't mean design,
but if you,
if you take that into consideration,
what,
what?
Uh,
what about a screen that's 60 feet tall
and brad pitt comes on and his bone
structure is fucking perfect and if it's
not,
they manipulate it and make it perfect
with three g cgi and every time he talks
music's playing and every word out of
his mouth is carefully considered.
Although It looks spontaneous,
it's not.
They've carefully considered this for
weeks and weeks for maximum impact on
your psyche and your sitting there and
the music's playing and he kisses
angelina jolie and oh,
like we're not designed for that.
So our,
our very exisTence,
the world that we live in,
our model of it is based like ninetY
percent on bullshit.
Ten percent of real life experiences,
90 percent on movies.
And I have a friend who got in a fight
with a guy and the guy said to him while
they're about to fight some drunken
thing,
prepare to dine in hell tonight.
We dine in hell.
He yelled out a fucking quote
from a stupid movie when they were about
to fist fight.
They were fist fighting,
like,
which could potentially leave it lead to
death.
I mean,
when you're involved in like actively
trying to hurt another human being,
all fucking bets are out the window.
This is chaos,
right?
And the guy's yelling at a movie quote
tonight.
We dine in the beginning of a beautiful
friendship.
We're just randomly sharing quotes back
from the grid.
We're off to see the wiz.
That's crazy.
You are.
My brother were crazy.
I don't think the,
the inspiration that I get from songs,
like there's songs that I'll listen to,
you know,
like,
um,
there's certain like,
like weightlifting.
Sorry,
I swear.
When you live,
listen to those songs,
you can lift more weights.
You can work out harder.
Like you're tired,
you're on the elliptical.
Machine.
Queen comes on like dragon attack and
you,
your,
your body reacts to it.
You have a physiological response to
media is something that's been created
that doesn't exist in nature with all of
nature's majesty,
with fucking waterfalls and flowers.
It never figured out how to make sound
come out of a headset.
That's just incredible.
It just makes your,
your,
your fucking goosebumps.
Raise up.
We've created some weird shit and in
creating that weird shit,
we're,
we're altering our very version of the
reality that we observe with our,
our real senses,
our eyes and our ears and our fingers
and we're changing it.
And this oculus rift shit,
it's going to take it to a whole new
place.
I mean,
it's gonna.
It's going to be as addictive as reality
tv is what?
It's stupidity.
It's going to be way more addictive.
If you could like,
look at any part of those people while
they're talking,
you know,
I mean,
you could do whatever you want.
You can move around in their world while
they're,
while they're existing.
You don't have to have a real,
a real
life.
You've seen wally.
I haven't.
Wally.
Wally was a good.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's a great film,
but everyone just ends up every human is
basically a fat useless slub that floats
around.
Can't even walk just on a big space line
floating around in space.
I'm useless.
Just gone watching tv.
What?
That sort of sped pessimistic version of
reality.
What do you think?
What's your version of reality?
This is because we're wrapping up.
We're running at three hours in when you
turn into a pumpkin,
so we're right about there.
Like what,
what is he,
what do you think is going to happen
with us?
Are you pessimistic?
Are you optimistic?
Do you enjoy the way the direction we're
moving ultimately?
Um,
the,
our scientific and engineering
achievement.
So astonishing and going beautifully
well.
I think it needs,
needs.
I'm,
I'm optimistic I think,
but I think it just needs a little.
I'm slightly
pessimistic at the moment.
I think it just needs this little nudge.
I think just a.
We've got the weed in countries like
ours,
right?
We've got these,
these education systems and these
universities that are broadly speaking,
very good.
They need a bit more money,
but they're pretty good and we've got a
culture that allows us to be open minded
and we have democracies and all these
things are very difficult to get.
So I think we often miss the great
things that we have in place in places
like the us and europe.
Definitely really very good.
And so,
so it just takes a recognition of that.
I think that's what we started again,
isn't it?
How do you just remind people what
wonderful opportunities they have and
what wonderful things there are to do.
And he just turned the reality tv off
for a bit and go and read a book or
something,
a kindle book.
Everyone doesn't have to be a real book.
Then,
you know,
what wonderful things could we achieve?
So I'm kind of optimistic there.
I think you do
beautiful.
I,
I think so.
I mean obviously there's some real
issues with culture and society,
but I often wonder as we talked about
before,
if those issues just inspire us to
improve and change.
And if you can't have a gun without a
yang,
I mean you have a bunch of shit going
on.
That is,
it's like a constant ebb and flow.
And I always,
I always ponder whether or not that is
a,
almost a mechanism for progress or a
mechanism for advancement and that
without it,
you don't get that.
I don't know.
It's possible.
It is possible.
So we can be optimistic at the end of
the.
Yes.
I think we wrapped it up nice.
I think we brought it home in a
beautiful way.
I can.
I say just because,
because my promoters sat over there and
I know he's been sitting there for three
hours.
He would like me to remind the viewers
that the infinite monkey cage tickets
are available online.
Monkey cage.com.
So you're on the,
you're on the,
uh,
the,
the la one,
which is the twelfth of the 12th of
March.
Yes.
At the ricardo montalban theater.
How ironic that fantasy island,
the guy from fantasy island,
that's who ricardo multiple was,
that we're going to be at the ricardo
montalban theater,
one of the dumbest fucking shows ever
fantasy island that had a little midget
boss deplane and yang thing,
the theater that the greater.
And then in san francisco,
the day after New York and chicago,
all the dates are
available@infinitemonkeycage.com.
Um,
thursday,
March 5th,
or in nyu at the skirball center in New
York city.
Doing that one actually.
Yes,
neil degrasse tyson,
astrophysicist john 11.
Did I say it right,
john?
Janet.
And then March 7th at the end.
Theni Anthony Anthony,
um,
theater in chicago,
uh,
with uh,
Paul Serrano,
paleontologist and evolutionary
biologist jerry coyne.
And then of course the twelfth with me
and a blossom.
The girlfriend blossom loss that she's
on the big bang theory.
Right?
And it's a feature on the.
Is there quick David Cohen,
emmy award winning writer.
Secret secret as well.
There might be.
That might be a pipe in the window.
And you got one March 13th about ufos,
alien probes and other close encounters.
Oh,
I want to be on that one.
You damn sure can't go to san francisco.
I'm busy that day.
Listen,
you're fucking awesome man.
Thank you very much for existing.
Thanks for doing what you do because
it's so important.
It's so exciting to me to be able to
watch your shows and to be able to just
sort of sponge that information from you
and thanks for just keep on keeping it
in three weeks and so I'll bring the
human universe stuff you.
I'll bring.
I'll bring you some crazy that's
downloaded on the yes.
Don't want to do whatever you gotta do
folks get back?
Alright,
we love you.
Thank you.
See you soon.
I enjoyed that.